cnn plus
in less than 30 days is being shut down
it's defunct and donald trump has come
out mocking them bless you trump thank
you so much for saying what so many of
us think we hate cnn we're glad to see
it go and i love it blue check
journalists are like well people need to
realize that cnn plus was the only news
streaming service and that was a bold
bet and apparently people just don't
want quality journalism believe it or
not they're actually saying that and i'm
like yo uh fox nation has been around
for four years and is fine the daily
wire is expanding like crazy and so are
we now we we we do political commentary
but what do you think it is when chris
wallace argues with jen sackey is that
news reporting no seen in his trash and
they failed and they deserve to fail and
elon musk is going to buy twitter lauren
southern's here
wow thanks for having me i'm glad you
got that out of your system tim i'm so
glad i'm so happy
i don't think people realize that cnn or
they're just realizing that it was like
the thing you watched at the airport
because it was the only thing on
like no one's going out of their way to
subscribe to cnn and now we've got
conclusive proof of this but
the amazing thing is the other day
sheamus was mentioning that it's like
nobody watches cnn so they're like i
have an idea let's charge them for it
yeah but but wait wait you know cred to
sheamus it's actually worse than that
they were like nobody watches cnn let's
charge them to watch our b-sides
like dude no one wants to see jake
tapper's book club like we don't watch
him as it is why do we want to watch him
talk about his books what were you
thinking he's actually my favorite
content creator
jake tapper content creator there was
some man i wish i could remember someone
on twitter who was saying that we should
refer to all of these media pundits as
content creators just because you can't
even imagine anyone referring to one of
these people as their favorite
i got the vibe well no because they
would get so angry by being called like
i'm a journalist that's also cnn we're
just calling them influencers
it's just good enough to maybe watch if
it's free yeah that was the vibe i
always got from cnn and i'm yeah it's
just a default well so we got sheamus
i'm seamus we just uploaded a cartoon
today on freedom tunes this video is
currently in first place out of our last
10 videos so i think you guys will
really enjoy it the audience is
currently really enjoying it
i love you all go check it out what's up
dudes i just rolled a 21. oh get it
going on it's your 21st birthday today
happy birthday are you telling me you
enrolled at 20 and a one and it is the
same time it's april 21st did you just
say all right 21 for april 21st let's go
they're expecting you to say uh finish
that sentence with a joint not 21.
i just rolled a joint no i did not no no
we're not gonna do that we're not doing
that on this show that's a different
kind of show love lauren glad she's back
so soon glad she's in the neighborhood
it's gonna be a great show let's go yeah
what do we look like joe rogan with elon
musk
anyway guys before we get started head
over to timcast.com become members
because as members you make all of this
possible and you keep our journalists
employed and we actually need to hire
many more journalists so we're we're
looking to expand our news operation but
it's not just about that it's about our
other shows pop culture crisis tales
from the inverted world chicken city has
become a smashing success and we just
launched our first chicken city cartoon
many many more to come and it's thanks
to you as members all this is possible
as a member you will get access to
exclusive segments of this show we'll
have a bonus members only show coming up
at 11 p.m tonight with lauren southern
it'll be a whole lot of fun so head over
to timcast.com sign up smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and now
let's read what papa trump has to say
about cnn timcast.com reports trump
mocks cnn and low-rated chris wallace
over failed streaming service
saying quote it was like an empty desert
out there despite spending hundreds of
millions of dollars and the hiring of
low-rated chris wallace a man who tried
so hard to be his father mike but lacked
the talent and whatever else is
necessary to be a star in any event it's
just one more piece of cnn and fake news
that we don't have to bother with
anymore trump continued wow
he said congratulations to cnn plus on
their decision to immediately fold for a
lack of ratings or viewers in any way
shape or form
absolutely incredible
bye-bye cnn i can't believe he just
threatened their safety like that oh
yeah
i will say mike wallace was pretty
awesome that i agree with him with i
this is like did you could you imagine
being chris wallace and being like
you're at fox news and then brian
stelter walks up and he's like would you
like to do a show and he's like well i
think that sounds like a great idea and
then he moves over and then within three
weeks he's fired
i'm obsessed with reading all the
articles about his mental state like the
updates it's like chris wallace telling
interns to read him the numbers every
hour chris was having mental breakdown
have you not seen these articles like he
was worried about his ratings yeah he
kept asking them to give him updates on
the numbers every day i i would promise
you that tim cast has more subs is there
do you think there are people out there
who are like you know they're they're
they're going to work and then they walk
up to the water cooler and there's like
a dude pouring water and they go hey you
see that chris wallace yesterday
like oh yeah good stuff i got to see
what wallace has to say you know every
night i go home what is he up to i think
the definition
pathetic is when you care about what the
audience thinks that's appeals appeals
wants the audience to feel something
that's that's pathetic uh i'm not 100
sure if that's the only use of it but
that's a big part of what that word
means yeah it's really
yeah i'll double check all that i want
to look into it
have you guys watched it at all like you
know cnn plus you know jokingly bought a
membership to see what's there that's
that's not funny that's not a joke why
would we do you know
do you know what i can do with three
dollars
i could do i could do so much that's
worth more than what cnn is only 70
dollars they they cut it in half
because people weren't yeah people
weren't signing up for six dollars
so they reduced it to 299
lifetime or whatever and i'm just like
do i want a cheeseburger or do i want to
watch cnn and yeah i gotta be honest
people aren't paying for this like
tucker carlson originals is taking off
you've got lots of these things starting
up it would have to be pretty bad for
them to say like oh we're not just going
to change strategy a bit
we're going to cut it off right now like
three weeks in it would have to be
brutal like i'd be curious to see those
numbers it was all scenes it was 150 000
paying monthly members
so
if you're doing you know six bucks a
month or whatever they're getting
they're not even cracking a million
bucks per month so you know they got a
good amount of money coming in per year
but with a 300 million dollar initial
investment and they were they were
planning on putting a billion dollars in
warner brothers isn't it just worrying
money into it warner brothers merges
with discovery and what they're saying
now is they're like
because of the merger cnn plus didn't
fit our plans and we want everything
housed under one streaming service and
i'm like oh yeah if cnn got a million
subs in one month they would not have
canceled it they would have been
celebrating cnn plus failed because cnn
plus is garbage because cnn is garbage
and garbage is not worth buying well
it's not just that they're wrong it's
that they're boring there are content
creators who i disagree with who i can
tune into every now and again just to
get their perspective on something about
me but true yeah exactly uh ian
specifically but the fact is if you want
people to pay for your subscription
service you have to have said something
at least mildly interesting at some
point in your life and i don't think
you'd qualify to work at cnn if you were
capable of that look at this tim cass
goes on
john nakozia the former managing editor
of mediaite recently reported he had
sources saying wallace was having daily
breakdowns over the state of cnn quote
source chris wallace is having daily
breakdowns over the miserable launch of
cnn plus wants a cnn show or is
threatening to walk they go on he is
having staffers count how many times a
day his promo is playing
yeah pathetic comes from patheticos
which is greek for subject to feeling
sensitive or capable of emotion it
wasn't necessarily tied to an audience
but it was usually because of the way
someone else treated someone i would not
want to be chris wallace's agent right
now
he's you know chris was on the phone
what's going on with my show
i have a solution oh yeah you know what
i would pay for i would pay if they
moved them transferred all these people
from cnn plus to disney plus and like
cast them in an early 2000s style disney
movie so right like luck of the irish
wait why are you looking at me it always
has to go there i had these like
horrendous amazingly offensive old
disney shows from the early 2000's those
were acceptable everyone from cnn in one
of those and like as like high school
people too since they always cast adults
as high school characters in disney
movies chris wallace high schooler
amazing yeah i mean i'd pay to watch
that to be honest
i got to be i got to be real if
cnn plus launched and their commercial
was that all of the hosts from cnn's
primetime and chris wallace would be
like cnn plus was literally just them
doing musicals
i actually would have subscribed to see
it yeah i'd be like i'd like to see
brian stelter pirouette yeah you know
and and it's a ridiculous thing i
wouldn't pay for in the long term but
i'd at least pay out of curiosity one
time to see what they're doing instead
they were like nobody wants to watch cnn
let's put our behind the scenes garbage
that's even worse for money and i'm like
i don't want to pay this tim why are you
giving them ideas i thought we're here
trying to build culture you want to
encourage cnn to do it
actually i mean that might be a hit show
i'm not even kidding you know making
making them do some kind of musical
number people might want to laugh at
them they went well and and to be fair
to be fair they will say anything for
money
that's true yeah will they sing anything
that's a good question are they capable
of singing we can maybe throw some auto
tune in there cnn hear me out i got a
pitch for you
it's a show
where you get
chris wallace for one hour you get
brian's out there for an hour you get
jake tapper and they have to read the
super chats whatever it is in
chronological order so that means like
brian selter would have to read exactly
what someone sends him yo i just want to
say you guys we would make a million
bucks a day
from people billions every single one of
those person's career would be over five
minutes into the first episode dude
that's the thing that's what's missing
is the interactivity between these
people in the audience like a good
journalist is gonna respond to questions
if about what their journalism is and
these people are like behind a glass
wall but it's not just the oh sorry no
like the first super chat for brian
stelter is someone would write i am a
potato i am a potato and he'd have to
read it and people would pay good money
for him to do that well this is the
thing it's not in it it's not just the
interactivity of it it's the personality
you're dealing with do you think people
would really like write into brian
stelton like maybe to mess with them or
if they were reading it but i just don't
think these people are entertaining or
charismatic enough yeah they're they're
parroting a line of lies i think for the
most part when i've seen a lot of stuff
come out of cnn the thing is i don't
want to say too much because i can't
think of any one thing off the top of my
head but it has felt like they've been
lying to me for a while or telling me
stuff that's not true whenever i've done
tv shows i've always like been like this
is amazing i just get to sit here and
say whatever i want and people on the
other side can't do anything about it
you just have to scream at your tv you
can't comment anywhere nothing i can
imagine that feels like very powerful to
them and the idea of ever exposing
themselves to their actual to the
peasants in the audience who may throw
tomatoes and that's what twitter is
basically
no no no right now i mean people are
saying things about you and you you do
not want to hear what they're saying let
me let me let me i want to hear it i'm
going to read it i'm going to read it
you think that you can escape one says
i love lauren southern ah i'm gonna
smash the like button
well tapped it back on shows like this
people actually for the most part it's a
bad day but it's nice yeah we're
debunking they rolled over
source
source like if we're really in a
psychological war fifth generational war
and they're not using the best
technology available to them they're
losing the psychological war people
aren't falling for it because they can't
respond they can't get through
i think cnn wants to lie and they don't
want you to be able to call them out if
cnn had a show where there was a live
chat next to it and they said it would
just be inundated with people being like
you're wrong about this you're wrong
about this we get people super chatting
us being like tim you are wrong here's
the fact and i'll read it and i'll be
like oh wow this is why sheamus is
correct tim you're completely wrong
about this
yeah
ian created a trend where he explained
that in dungeons and dragons a one is a
critical failure and 20 is a critical
success so now every time ian says
something they either put one or twenty
in the chat actually my new twitter
image now is uh pictures i saw that i
love that yeah it's incredible wait oh
no i didn't see that i think i saw you
post something and it was a bunch of
twenties maybe i think it's so then you
should you go to my twitter profile
stock design on twitter thanks for
making those images man that is
fantastic you're about to get some
feedback ian you're about to get the
thing cnn is afraid
one's in the chat one's in the chat boys
no no it's not true critical critical
miss no no they're rolling me once
well without cnn what do we do where do
we go make another one feel lost well
we're already doing it it's the reason
why cnn is failing is because of shows
like this and other awesome like shows
where people can interact and relate to
the audience
i think and do good research did cnn
plus you know i gotta be honest i didn't
actually
look so i don't know if they had any
kind of interactivity they might have
it's history i mean a streaming service
i just i love it was wesley lowry who
used to be with washington post he did
this big twitter thread about how they
were the only news streaming service and
it was a huge bet that doesn't pay off
because regular people don't want to pay
for good reporting and i'm just like
like like daily wire has so many
subscribers he said good reporting tim
not right wing bigotry
honestly they could have paid their
users to watch that's another model that
may have worked maybe with crypto or
something they did they did that with uh
the airports
well no not really but they forced
people to watch if you know what i mean
you know what i think tim i think cnn
plus is actually failing because too
many people are sharing passwords oh
yeah that's right everyone wants to
watch it you know what i love too is how
uh with with tv ratings they say you
know 100 households instead of 100 you
know people so that way they're like
well households could be five people
and or it could mean that the show
wasn't on at all as if the whole family
gathers around sits on the couch to
watch brian stelter together
maybe in the 80s i don't think that
happens weren't they disparaging him who
like the discovery guys were like brian
stelter is terrible or something like
that
really i mean i got to be honest i can't
imagine
i'm trying to think of what kind of
person
looks at brian stelter and says he
should have his own show
like like you listen to him and he's
like we should we should give him a show
i got a mixed feelings about him i can't
tell what is the reason because when i
look at him i'm like all right he looks
like when he has that really fake
there's a picture of him like doing the
joker smile where it's like yeah his
eyes are normal but his mouth is why is
that i got this scar did he know
somebody like growing up did he have his
dad was connected to somebody my father
was a reporter like chris wallace's dad
was mike wallace he worked for the new
york times okay and apparently like he
got a job there when he was really young
i think his same age as me yeah he is
yeah crazy so did he do really good
reporting in the early days i don't know
he interviewed me after occupy wall
street yeah i don't hate the guy i just
he said a lot of weird stuff and i think
he's
a very very bad person
you know he lies all the time yeah and
he he plays this you know ridiculous
game i think when you're on a show like
that people who are willing to play the
game and be loyal and not question
things are almost more valuable than
good reporters because there would be so
many people that are new hires that just
get jaded so quickly by getting that
script in and when you have a stelter
who's just like i'll read it every day
consistently won't ask questions lies
don't care like that's more valuable to
these networks is that that loyalty to
lies than
good reporting to something the funniest
thing about cnn plus was that it was
obviously failing to everybody with all
the stories that were breaking was like
a day after it launched they announced
that they were planning on just shutting
it down and i still saw these
establishment journalists trying to
promote it not even seeing an employees
being like wow really great stuff from
cnn plus i'm like nobody said shut up
it's terrible what are you tweeting like
this one guy who works these
institutional journalists these
university professors
are tweeting videos from cnn plus and
i'm like that's that's awful
and but they're tr i'm like why are you
trying so hard to make cnn a thing
nobody wants to watch it
what if they're a burger review guy on
cnn plus
there was a burger review guy
yeah okay
i'm not making this up i'll find it i
promise we'll keep talking
well they need stuff like that if they
want to succeed they need to branch out
or out of politics into other cultural
issues like sports and i don't know well
they either a have to they have to do
two things all right stop lying
bring some interesting people on board
both ideally
but even if they do i think their
credibility has just been so completely
destroyed that that wouldn't even save
them or or they could lie more oh or oh
why didn't i think of that
tripling down as though if they came out
and told news stories that were just so
shockingly absurd it would be
entertaining to watch like the baby
right we are no longer a real news
network we are now satire like
could you imagine if brian stopper came
out they would change a thing the
executives realized that we were on the
border of that anyway so we decided to
dip one foot in and see what happens
donald trump did a backflip today and he
landed perfectly on target he dove off
of a 200-foot
diving board to a kiddie pool like
techno music underneath his his
deliveries and stuff like if he really
wants his new show to be popular they
got to put like a dubstep underneath him
you know why he's talking i i got to be
honest
if they launched a show on cnn plus
where was brian stelter arguing with a
duck i would pay for oh one million
percent one million percent and then you
could almost like super chat in like
with chicken city and then like bread
will drop like when the chicken's really
winning like the chickens really got the
best of him you're like dude there's a
point for this this is a point for the
dog
but when brian's winning you press a
button and a donut falls down
in the 1950s they would always talk like
this and there was this weird thing it's
like oh golly gee dad and then all of a
sudden in the 60s everyone took lsd or
all these people and they like broke out
and we're like why do people sound and
then they start talking normal like we
do we're going through it again with
this industry they sit and they have
this news delivery voice that they do
and you're like what is this
theater this crap they're behind a desk
with a tie on you like what the and then
you see real people talking and it's
we've shattered that reality again
do you think you're a cultural
revolution i should put on a suit and
talk like this for today's news donald
trump and a backflip yeah weird news
you're talking about are you talking
about the mid-atlantic accent i'm not
sure what that is no no no no no no okay
so the news presenters so for one thing
their microphones couldn't catch
mid-ranges as well so they sound very
squeaky and dark like this there's that
but then there's also the acting style
where they were like oh gee pop oh there
was an actual accent that they developed
the advent of mass media i think it's
called transatlantic or mid-atlantic
yeah and the idea was they wanted an
accent that would sound familiar to
everyone in the country yeah because
there were different dialects spread out
everywhere and so a lot of public
presenters learned how to speak this
fabricated dialect and then it fell out
of fashion well the actors they they
adopted what was meant to sound high
class by adopting a british non-erotic
style of speaking without the
harshness of the british accent so
they'd say darling where's my car so the
r's were basically dropped and it was
more of just like a taut thing
but yeah i would love nothing more to
see that stupid news speak just
completely go by the way when they talk
like this to tell you about the story
the thing that happened today it's very
weird can you imagine if someone talked
to you like that and really like what if
you had someone on this podcast like
well tim my opinion is that the drink
that you have right now doesn't need
those cherries and sheamus we'll we'll
hear more in this conversation in a
moment exactly like what but like at
what point in time was that ever it
seems like one of those things where
because you couldn't get audience
feedback they just started talking like
slightly more weirdly and never noticed
how bizarre it was
i remember when i was uh when i got jobs
when i got a job working for that for
fusion which is abc and they asked me to
do live hits and i would hear
the other people be like i'm standing
here on the ground in ferguson yes
around me several protesters and i would
just be like i'm here in ferguson
there's protesters around me and people
are pretty angry
yeah that's what i did at my college
you're talking like that they're like he
goes back he tries to catch the ball but
he didn't he missed it i was trying to
do the sports at like at my college that
was obvious it's like the way uh vosh
talks there's a clip of him he's like i
have been beset
by fatigue
i must rest
well i think
i guess
we have that study where they they
they talk down to black people you saw
that yell study
what they like is people who sound smart
so you'll see there's a lot of feminists
they'll write in extremely verbose and
confusing ways and it's like really
annoying instead of just saying outright
like the dog jumped over the fence
they'd be like
a animal of the canine variety made a
strong leap over an obstruction in the
middle of a yard full of grass and you'd
be like
yeah it's like meant to sound just be
normal
it's like uh it's like when you're 14
years old and you're trying to write an
essay yeah in your english class and
you're just patting it like how do i
reach the word here yeah they give you
word limits that's part of it too is you
need to fill out a quota of words if
they were just like write me the best
story and if you can do it the short
honestly the more concise and simple you
can make a message the better it is in
general yeah it's funny because i mean
most of what i do is cartoon writing but
i've done column writing in the past and
basically everything i was taught in my
formal education about writing was
completely wrong obviously aside from
the rules of grammar but this idea that
you have a you have a minimum number of
words you're supposed to make it long
and wordy when in reality people want
what you write to be concise i think
that we should begin to talk more like
this and try to use a style of speaking
that is more professional and enunciated
because then people will assume that we
are smarter than we actually are wise
words well tim frankly i prefer the
newscaster way of speaking i think it's
much more intelligent studies show that
you're wrong i guess that people
no real question like why do they talk
like i think it all came from the
original newscaster that did it and then
although he just created a genre and
people didn't really start copying it he
like sustained some kind of head injury
as a child so he couldn't speak normal
and they heard him like i just
that's how he was talking that's how i'm
gonna do it it's like nirvana came out
and all these other bands started
sounding like nirvana that's different
that's because record labels started
taking those bands specifically they
existed yeah but there is the story of
the uh king of catalonia so in spain
there's the catalan lisp when i was in
barcelona yeah when i was in madrid yeah
this is funny i went to madrid and i
said cerveza and then this guy goes
no no no
and i went really he's like thie and i
went oh okay and then i said fidova and
someone started laughing and they were
like
no no no cerveza and i was like all
right whatever man the legend i was told
is that there was a a king who had a
lisp and so everyone was like oh i want
to talk like the king and so they all
adopted the list in chile also
chile if
so like
obviously journalistic ethics are
supposed to be neutral when you're
discussing stories so maybe they just
thought if i sound neutral while saying
extremely biased false things people
will assume
i am neutral on the subject donald trump
is a fascist
donald trump drowned 17 kittens
according to an anonymous source
if you say it like that and you're not
like seething and screaming then people
will be like wow newscaster person told
me fact maybe maybe you know it would be
fun if we actually launched a
semi-cetera
semi-satirical column that's true
but in like
not the right kind of way so like what
what i would do is i would go to nancy
pelosi's office
find a homeless guy near her office
and ask him to say things that were
ridiculous and then i would quote him
and say a source near nancy pelosi's
office confirmed
so it's like it's true but like
not right i love that
nancy pelosi eats
raw fish a source closer do they do that
do they like go next door to nancy
pelosi's office like two guys and then
one guy asks the other guy a question
and then
because it's totally it's legal right
they do stuff like that but not that
over they have what they have one guy go
inside the building and talk to him from
out the window and he goes an inside
source
to make statements of fact that are
judgment-proof dirty
another theory i have is if you are less
human on air then people
go after you less if you're not a
personality and you're just kind of like
this npc have you guys ever watched
sorry random pivot uh best of enemies
gore versus uh gorbadol versus buckley
no oh oh i think
is a good example of a transatlantic
accent by the way well they it 1968 they
had these debates on abc i think it was
they were like the first live debates
during elections and they just went at
each other and i think they all ended
when buckley called uh yeah vidalia can
i say yeah no no you can't no
you can allude to it there's an evolve
there's an f involved and then the other
f slur was thrown by vidal towards
buckley called her fascists and then
they like clashed and it like ended and
i think all these other newscasters were
like ooh we don't want to get that messy
that was like too real for us he also he
said he called him that the the word
that would get the stream taken down and
he also threatened to hit him because i
believe he called him a nazi even though
buckley it was was bucky called him he
called him a crypto fashion yeah so
gorbador was a far leftist and buckley
was was founder of the national so
if it's been that long and this stuff's
still been happening perhaps we're going
to be all right yeah yeah yeah well they
you should watch the movie they're like
just fantastic debates we just have
nothing like that on tv anymore that was
like great television yeah yeah he was
like national review why didn't cnn plus
do that i know i know you know you know
it really boosts cnn's ratings right now
if they just had on people like uh alex
jones
if if brian stelter really wants ratings
he can bring on alex jones
um sorry yeah vidal versus buckley but
with jones and seldom and it's gotta be
in studio where they can't cut each
other's mics and stuff like that
and i say do it live but good luck but
that's what they got to do if you want
to step up to the plate you guys really
want to want to contend with what's
happening in reality right now do it
live someone just had to keep lauren
away from the whiskey
i went over there and there's nothing to
me
that was so sad what do you mean
there's nothing to that you got espresso
chocolate and then just hard liquor
i guess you could put the whiskey in
coffee yeah i could i'll be right back
all right all right let's talk about
twitter though we got the story elon
musk man
from timcast.com elon musk secures
financing of 46.5 billion to complete
cash purchase of twitter so here's the
gist of it elon musk made an offer he
said i want to buy this company the
board did not respond so he raises the
cash and says i've got the cash now i'd
like to negotiate
if they don't he'll move to a tender
offer where he just outright says i'll
buy the company for 46.5 billion so
everything he's doing seems to be
strategic and planned out and planned
out for some time elon musk filed the
sec paperwork on 4 20. that is not a
coincidence
we know this man and so i'm willing to
bet with that look at this picture we
got off him look at him look at him
smiling like that he knows what he's
doing
he's got a plan oh elon musk is great
i strive to be at the point he has i
wasn't i wasn't the biggest fan of him
several years ago and moving forward but
recently
the way he's engaged on twitter the
things he's been doing i'm just like
i hope that we can have a company that
engages in the kind of culture jamming
that he does that we can get to that
point where we buy a company because
it's doing bad things and we fix it but
uh my point is
i think in the next week or so we may
actually see a major move because if he
actually makes a a a tender offer
then they have no choice but to open the
floor to bidding because they have a
fiduciary responsibility fiduciary duty
to their shareholders
he's ruffling and ruffling up some
feathers man at the very at the very
least he may drive up the stock he owns
and make a bunch of money off it but i
think he's gonna win i think one way or
another elon musk wins this one when did
he mention that he was coming in on it
was it early april do you guys remember
the exact day because it was april 1st
is when this the spike the stock started
to spike or was it march 30. was it the
8th or something like that let me see if
it's wonder people knew ahead of time
that he was coming in on that but the
stock just started to rise from 40 bucks
on on march 31st and now it's sitting at
like 46. i bet somebody knew 50. man he
is the most valuable thing that could
ever happen to that company at this
point
morgan's not morgan stanley honestly i
think um
honestly they need they're going to do
everything to push him out because their
agenda at this point for some bizarre
reason isn't to make money
across yeah but i mean i can't imagine
someone who'd be more confident there he
actually values allowing people to
express themselves freely on that
platform well sheamus morgan stanley is
reportedly coming in at nearly half the
cost we'll have more as the story
develops
what an exciting development we'll be
hearing about that after this break so
is that 26 billion 26 billion or what is
it 23 billion
i think elon's putting in what 21 of his
own do we have the numbers here
uh let me let me i just got a message
from michael robison robison robeson
what's up uh april 9th was the day that
he announced that april 9th right
right so i think he did it on april 8th
robeson or robinson i asked him the
other night too well i don't know
michael robinson whatever uh let's see
do we have the numbers and the actual
filing it's just too many letters for me
to scan through at the moment you know
there's no wonder that they're not in it
to make money seemingly you look at the
board members that have been published
and they don't own that much stock there
are people on the board that own zero
stock on twitter yeah it was published
and elon even commented on his himself
he's like what is going on here yeah
point zero zero two percent of the
company and they're on the board point
zero zero zero zero and look at
how jack dorsey is behaving right now
too he's randomly become based he's like
speaking out against cnn he's talking
about how there's issues behind the
scenes at twitter i wonder what he knows
that we don't about what's happening but
clearly his money is more important to
him
but he's also an illegal battle isn't he
so there would be legal implications i'm
sure oh it's robeson michael not sorry
not a legal battle but he'd have
documents he would have signed
non-disclosure all these things yeah he
couldn't that's what i'm saying his
money's worth more to him i mean
he's being real subtle yeah so it's okay
21 his job 21 billion from uh i believe
from elon musk himself 13 billion from
morgan stanley let's see what else
there's
uh 500 million from senior secured
revolving facility in an aggregate
commitment amount i don't know i think
morgan stanley is doing 13 he's doing 21
and then there's uh
a loan and some other numbers but morgan
stanley is coming in big on this i think
anybody who sees what's going on knows
that elon musk taking over twitter
twitter is money to be made how many
users have left the platform because of
the banning of donald trump talk about
the worst business decision you could
ever make well i think bringing them
back on is also a weird decision i mean
why because getting in there and just
starting making editorial decisions
about who can and can't be on the the
network is not the way to go forward
with that network right you open it back
up to people for free speech yeah that's
one way to do it is unban every account
on the network uh and start from scratch
you could do that and then free the
software code so other people can spin
up other twitters with their own terms
of service you unban accounts that were
banned for political reasons donald
trump was banned because he he said
things that they did not like he did not
do anything illegal anybody who's done
something illegal you don't want the
platform
uh okay well this is a this is a long
conversation um there are a lot of
things you shouldn't be able to do on
social media in my opinion platforms
that are legal like uh you know alluding
to child pornography for instance wait
what
uh it's free speech you're allowed to
talk about it and show you know well yes
yes yes you're a lot so so you're
allowed to spam people that's not
illegal but it also destroys a social
network so there's things that you have
to go outside of the law and you can
make them
and elon musk wants to uh verify humans
to deal with the sp the bots and the
spam and twitter won't take care of this
okay now that's something because people
make new account new account new account
news and then you keep spam spam that's
right that's where they go after like i
p addresses and i think these and stuff
and if they did verified only which you
can do when you're verified you can say
only show me verified only show me
verified mentions so you don't get
spambots but regular people don't have
that making it a hostile terrible
platform to be on who's uh verifying
that's a that's another question they
have to have a connection to an official
news network to get a verified check
mark which is wild to me i got verified
because vice made a phone call yeah
exactly so i had like 35 000 followers
there were a bunch of activists asking
why i wasn't verified they were like hey
tim's been featured in these magazines
and he's a journalist why isn't he
verified but why is this guy with 500
followers verified and twitter i
actually was invited to a party in
silicon valley and there was a guy who
worked for twitter who was there and
asked him about it and he was like oh
you know it's just we got to get around
to it so we'll probably get you because
we're just going through but it's bs
vice made a phone call and then i
instantly had a verification check mark
he's lying you actually have to be a
member of the cia yes that's how i got
mine right right uh so fans with elon
musk's plan it's
if you're paying for the service twitter
blue you get verified i completely agree
with that five bucks a month and what
happens is when you wait any way anyone
anyone can be verified now if they pay
for that service elon musk's plan
is that anybody who has twitter blue
gets verified
i don't know that's just i don't know
that's helpful i agree with it really
but like
the verified thing is just to detect
like who's a fake account or a copycat
of a big figure that would get a lot of
copycats so it'll deal with sock puppets
and it'll deal with spam bots
so one person running 50 accounts won't
be able to have a check mark on all of
his accounts only one of them so that
right right there you know what people
don't understand is cancel culture works
because of sock puppetry
one activist will operate 50 accounts
through different phones so they have
different ip addresses and different mac
addresses and then they'll start
spamming you and other people will have
fake accounts to spam you within lie
under his plan a regular person can
spend five bucks just five bucks you can
go on you know and not everybody has it
i know but the people who want it will
get verified and then you could say i
only want to interact with other people
who are verified and bot farms couldn't
make money off of that yup yeah it's
like people don't realize but literally
in third world countries they just have
these farms of people you can pay a
hundred dollars on websites to get a
thousand tweets of whatever you want at
10 000 likes it's
cheap you can so there's videos showing
how they'll have like a wall with cell
phones every every inch yeah and they're
all signed into different accounts and
you'll say i want a hundred tweets
telling this person that they're a bad
person and they'll go okay okay and
they'll say things like this is terrible
you suck this is not it wrong and
corporations see that they panic like oh
no people are yelling at us we better
cancel our sponsorships with the h3h3
podcast because he's bad and then they
do it
i have a post on instagram
that has over thirty 000 comments all
saying the exact same thing
like you wouldn't think that's possible
someone would have had to pay a pretty
penny to do that it's all saying i'm a
man
i don't know why someone would pay to do
that true in canada but yeah i was gonna
say i thought you had that legally
changed in canada yeah i did uh seniors
there you go so confirmed now by bot
farms pay-to-play social networks aren't
my favorite idea no i understand the
short-term value of it though but you
could still the ccp or the u.s
government could pay 600 million dollars
to get a bunch of people verified and
then trick you into thinking that
they're they're not bots
in order to be verified
you have to pay
you have to have an account where money
is coming so they would have to verify
you
yeah but i'm saying that money could
come from like a nefarious actor right
i'm just saying elon musk's plan is to
have you pay and they would verify your
identity it's it makes money for them
they can cover the cost of verifying you
wouldn't
couldn't they just do what facebook does
which i don't like because it plays into
all the digital id stuff but you have to
upload like your driver's license to
have an account so no one can create
multiple accounts they do that you
haven't had to do that on facebook no
i've had facebook apparently the csis
are just trying to get my idea there's
pluses and minuses to both that whole
thing like tracking you and knowing who
you are and where you are is has its
value because you're on the network now
and people can find you but the downside
is if the government goes crazy and you
need to do some revolutionary war stuff
then
you you don't want them to know like ben
franklin if he'd been on facebook that's
what it came to his house before the
revolution ever kicked off so it's
almost too late now because the people
think like oh digital id is just like
linking your accounts with your you know
real life id all of this like having
your face scan fingerprints but it's
more than that they can now detect your
digital identity by your typing habits
the pressure you put down on your
keyboard on your smartphone so your
mouse movements even if you're yeah even
if you're anonymous living in the woods
somewhere they can detect
mass data sweep of who's got the same
pressure points on their smartphone the
code of the network oh that's a good
point because it's the phone itself the
code of the networks need to be free
copy left licenses so you can see if
they're giving that data away but then
so does the phone
data the phone software code needs to
also be free so you can see if the phone
itself is doing it before it even gets
to the program and it's
sensing you i like this freedom phone
concept i haven't used one yet but
phones like that and i would agree but
the question is how do you get the
average person to really care about it
enough to make consumer decisions that
will
cause companies to change the way they
manufacture these things in the way they
give your data the evil way to get
people to do his fear yeah that's been
the go-to way for a lot of
authoritarians
um the right way to do it is build
something that is so amazing that they
want to use it instead i think we could
make a cheeky authoritarian government
in it'd be fun it would be really fun i
think we could see it
i'd actually be really interested to see
an ian authoritarian authoritarian
stratosphere delivery man there would be
like a guy like the cop is wearing like
tie-dye armor and he walks up to some
dude wearing a suit and he goes where's
your crystal
it's right here and it pulls it out and
it'll be the one where they're like ian
we want you to be king and i'll be like
i'm stepping down and the software code
is free no no just like george
washington i mean what if they tell you
to step down you're like i'm gonna be
king
oh okay psychological warfare right
reverse psychology i'd step down it's
time
to do what's right once a week you have
mandatory dmt
you know
it's it's you know once a month you have
to do um
extended state dmt the guards are
wearing like they're you know tie-dye
armor with you know tie-dye guns and
they're like right this way dude
mandatory meditation if dmt was legal
would you guys would you do it
no is it not legal
in the right environment right certain
places basically
some places like for medic for spiritual
like um
i don't think dmt outright but like
ayahuasca is protected i think under
some native american protection religion
laws and like peyote and stuff but uh
regardless i would not dude what were
you going to say
oh no i don't think i would
oh
your court system your judicial system
and the the authoritarian society would
just be rolling a dice it'd be like it's
a 120 man that's a one or a twelve we do
need an upgrade to our judicial our
entire system needs a big it needs an
upgrade i mean they're facing execution
you just look at them ever played dnd
role initiative yeah
see what he gets you you roll in your
court case like the prosecutor has
rolled the 17. what i want to do is
bring american ideals basically
constitutional ideals to the world if we
could but i don't want to do it through
a war you know that's what they've been
trying to do for the last 70 years and
obviously it's not working
maybe maybe like encourage them to
change i don't know like the arab spring
looked like it but they didn't fall we
didn't help them let me ask you a
question ian um what would you do to
convince sheamus not to be catholic
be my best self
no okay uh but then you'd become
catholic
wait hold on hold on hold on no
what is it what i'm asking a literal
question i don't want him to not be
catholic then how so so it's what you
need to understand about the war and
stuff that goes on in these countries
you have a bunch of people who couldn't
do jumping jacks do you guys see that
video when we tried training the iraqi
soldiers they could not do jumping jacks
the the no they weren't jumping jacks it
was the military version what are their
whatever they're called
and they were trying to train it was the
afghan armed forces i'm sorry did you
see this video
and they're like they're they're going
like this
and the guy's like hands up hands down
and they go
and start like swinging one arm like
they just could not do it we could bring
islam and christianity together i think
islam needs a reformation
they can come convert to us but well
hold on hold on christianity i want i
think ian's right we got to send him to
palestine right away
well i'm not talking about running up to
the crowd and be like change i'm just
saying that i think there needs to be
like a cohesive you know unification of
these concepts all right because you
guys take christians have more in common
with muslims than they do with atheists
in america for sure
absolutely well
hold on this work is on on some matters
but then a lot of atheists are running
around with christian moral foundations
and just don't realize it
yeah but i'm just talking about like
that step between i don't believe
there's a greater power that controls
our civilization and life and soul to i
believe in god and that dynamic is so
big that you know monopolism yeah
judaism as well it's all wrapped in it's
monotheistic concept it's not even it's
it's not even about monotheism in my
opinion it's about believing in
something greater than you yeah that's
it you know whether whether it's the
rights of other people whether it's a a
god or an afterlife it feels like very
much what separates the left from the
right in the modern context is whether
the world is about you or the world is
about everything i liked martin luther
because he seemed to see that it was
about his connection to god directly and
less about going through a church that i
liked a lot if we could bring that to
islam as well i like that why is built a
church why does the media lie
because they believe the destruction
they cause is justified for
several reasons one either they want to
make money they care more about
themselves than the greater society or
two they think their vision of the world
is better than yours which is once again
about them
but that's so interesting because they
obviously used to be you know for the
group for the leftist kind of
perspective was the union the people but
that's completely shifted and i think
that's why i saw someone tweeting about
this that they wanted libs of tick tock
censored because
they used to have the working-class
union man and that has been the power of
the left and they are losing that fast
with these people seeing what is going
on with these like hardcore
individualist liberals in schools you
have the populist expanse on the right
is resulting in some left economic
policies finding their way to
conservatives you now have tucker
carlson bringing on the guy who formed
the amazon union and saying good good
for you amazon's a big evil corporation
and i'm like i agree with tucker i think
amazon is absolutely terrible we're all
addicted to it because it's convenience
but boy are they nasty and so tucker
is now like you know i disagree with
unions in the past but i appreciate you
guys sticking it to the big evil
corporations and then you have you have
the left cheering for saudi arabia
cheering for china cheering for disney
cheers
in the house they're like give them tax
cuts
that was amazing so so the house voted
uh you know what do we have this one i
don't know i'll get that video up i'm
gonna go get some i don't know if i have
the video pulled up but uh uh in the
house on uh in florida they voted to
take away the special governing
privileges and tax privileges from
disney and the activists were like no
give the corporations power give the
corporations 20 off their taxes the
colorado governors wanted to bring
disney to colorado he was like hey we'll
uh set you guys up and basically what
i'm thinking is yeah right like if
disney goes to colorado spends 100 like
billions of dollars building disney
world plus or whatever they want to call
it uh and then a new governor gets in
and it's like we're shutting down disney
special privilege and like what does
this guy think is going to happen anyway
he wants to bring him out there and give
him access to build nuclear power plants
again
i'm not seeing it so this is the this is
the the video we have here from twitter
it's about uh in the house the florida
house
was voting to strip disney of their
special privileges which would be like
their special governance abilities their
ability to police or build nuclear power
plants and special tax privileges and we
ended up with this protest let me make
sure we have the the audio appropriately
configured
[Applause]
all right you can't really hear them but
they're they're apparently chanting this
is good trouble this is necessary
trouble um
it's from the a reporter from the
orlando sentinel so you actually have
the left
they are in the chambers
protesting that a one of the largest
corporations in the world is losing a
tax cut good they're allowed to do it i
support the right to do it i don't agree
with your message though no i think that
they're cultists for the corporation and
they probably mickey mouse plushed
animals in their couch and stuff we all
recognize their right to protest we are
pointing out the psychosis that is
occurring when the left is like
corporations should have tax cuts people
are obsessed with it
some people are it's a mutually oh sorry
no no they're truly late it's like a
cult of disney they have stuffed animals
of ariel the mermaid and stuff like what
the heck i would say it's not exactly
that it's almost this mutually parasitic
relationship the left sees disney as a
vehicle for promoting their ideas and
disney believes that they can extract
some profit from left-wing audience
members if they promote those ideals and
as soon as either doesn't need the other
or they rise to power and get what they
want they're going to throw each other
under the bus yeah it's tough to tell
what these specific people what their
intentions were i don't know if they
were trying to support evil no they were
saying it was racist
right
um what a shock
so i guess i guess this this protest
wasn't actually about disney though so
i think this one there was a protest i'm
pretty sure there's a protest about the
disney thing apparently this one was was
it was from the uh uh the black caucus
or something in florida i think actually
just give me fake news if you're going
to be fake news you have to go
today disney was protested i i can send
you the video on let me see if i could
pull up tonight they were chanting fight
back fight back
yeah but i think that might have been
something different maybe no let
oh they're way too powerful you know
power is the right word because money
isn't going to get what i what i saw on
twitter earlier was people saying that
they were protesting the disney thing
like the disney vote was happening but
the orlando sentinel says they were
protesting something that would remove
black democratic lawmakers or something
like that so you guys think we should
break up disney the monopoly is it a
monopoly yet it owns marvel at bought
maker studios after i was building that
thing well so so right
floridapolitics.com says house passes
bill ending disney plus carve out gavels
uh gavels out amid protests okay i want
what i just sent you sorry i can't pull
it up on this computer can you tell me
how to find it on twitter yeah what's
the tweet i'll retweet it
listen to that
dead space
hot air sorry i'm so bad with
interrupting who owns disney that's what
i'm looking for right now what's your
at lauren underscore southern this was
all a an elaborate plot to get people to
follow my twitter
underscore
i can't believe you're still on twitter
and still vote on these two bills
it is my hope that we will be able to
proceed civilly
and with decorum and with respect for
one another read the next bill
it's like the 1800s under bradley senate
bill 4c built to be entitled and act
related to independent special districts
no i think they're protesting something
about independent special districts is
the territory that did right but the
people are yelling something about black
people standing up and fighting back i
think what happened so it spilled into
the second one look at the headline here
house passes bill ending disney plus
carve out gavels out amid protests you
see what they do
they make the story about that and then
they say it's a mid-protest so you
assume the protests are actually about
disney keep playing that video though
let's see if they are still yelling
about
oh i can't hear it yeah i think the
sound was cut
[Music]
i mean look she's making good fine you
recognize to explain your bill
you mr speaker i can't hear what they're
saying they're saying something
into this when black lawmakers under
attack what do we do stand up fight back
i wonder if there's a quote in here
because yeah
okay well you maybe you caught me on
some fake news here that's good like
dude if you're gonna do fake news you
have to do in the newscaster voice
lauren no no no no i don't that's the
mistake i made i don't blame you for it
because this is exactly what i saw as
well they're like everyone's all of
these people were tweeting
they passed the bill cutting out
disney's taxes amid protests and you
can't really hear what the protests are
saying and when you look at news
articles that frame it this way can we
pull this one up again when they
literally say they they passed the bill
ending the carve out amid protests
they're manipulating you into thinking
the protests were about that i am not
fake news i am a victim of fake news
yeah really i've gone through that a lot
writing articles with minds in the early
days like at what point do you have to
pass do you pass the buck or take
responsibility when you read a fake
article and then you present it to the
masses yeah yeah so they said the
protests began as democrats debate time
expired on the bill to pass
congressional maps drafted by desantis's
office democrats called desantis
involvement a breach of the separation
of powers and argued the maps would
reduce the representation of black
floridians in congress
in a statement after the house adjourned
sprouls issued a statement accusing some
members of violating house rules and
hijacking the process so yeah what they
were protesting was that the the map
congressional map is going to cut out
two black lawmakers okay so we got we
got taken for a ride by these headlines
but uh we caught it we caught it i
didn't i didn't believe a word of it at
all you guys no i mean like we corrected
this stuff well that's a good way this
is conversational when you just have
newscaster voice reading it you don't
get the back and forth the real-time
correction well see i actually typically
what happens with us is i didn't pull up
that story because i couldn't hear what
they were yelling so when you brought up
i was like oh yeah you know like i heard
that too it's a good thing we pulled it
up though because now these headlines i
mean come on man look at this headline
that headline is going to be on twitter
someone's going to see it and that's
exactly what happened with what i what i
s that's exactly what happened to me i
saw that and i was like oh yeah i heard
that those people were were protesting
tax cuts and then you pulled up and
you're like ah they got me yeah
just reading past the headline is a
superpower where where is snopes when
you need them you know
fact check false they could have put
like amid war and because they're
talking about the war in ukraine we
didn't mean anything about like right
that's that's something that you got to
be really careful of too because um
depending on what the headlines you use
for stories are
so
it's tough because i'll i'll do youtube
videos that way when i'm trying to make
a point about two things happening
simultaneously or having some
relationship
but you see how the media will do it
they'll say something like you know
ian ian crossland throws out uh throws
major fit as sheamus steals lucky charms
which is true you think sheamus stole
them and that's why he's angry and then
you read it like sheamus was 20 miles
away when it happened eating the lucky
charms on video oh the best one it was
no what was it news newsweek no i'm not
going to say that i can't remember who
it was but they published that uh
a woman who criticized putin had died
she had disappeared been kidnapped and
died and then when you read the article
her boyfriend had murdered her
but the headline and the photo was a
picture of putin and this woman that's
interesting
shout out to media matters
that article they they published an
article saying you know podcast host
says something about gay marriage
yeah they said uh it was like tim cast
irl host
uh attacks marriage equality
and uh
says it leads to grooming and it was
part of a conversation that we had where
i stated my position which is that there
is no such thing as gay marriage
marriage is between a man and a woman uh
but the person who tweeted it out was
basically trying to make it sound like
tim had changed his position on gay
marriage right let me show this so media
matters wrote
tim cast irl panelists attack marriage
equality suggested has led to
normalizing grooming they show you know
here's the thumbnail for this video it's
me and then they actually say i think
they said in the tweet you got to watch
out for these grifters changing their
positions and in it it's like i can't
remember if it was the media matters
tweet or if it was it was the first
iteration of it i saw i need to double
check i wasn't on that show that night
either that's really annoying
so it's like me saying
the issue for me is it's not gay
marriage or slippery slope fallacy i
think two consenting adults is not the
issue obviously there's a lot of
traditional conservatives have an issue
with that i disagree the issue is with
children who can't consent that's always
been the point it's like
i'm i literally we have a discussion
with jason whitlock and i'm like i'm
okay with gay marriage i think it's a
good thing but like i don't like the
slippery slope fallacy in this context
because i'm like dude if something is
bad it's bad then you don't say
because of this might make something bad
no no say no to bad things you say okay
to good things or to things that are
aligned with your values you debate them
too that's what the show's all about
well it's funny because after i made my
point which was absolutely correct and
absolutely accurate you said you
disagreed with me so they just as easily
could have made the headline tim poole
supports our you know lame left-wing
position on this
uh
well i shouldn't be but i am surprised
that this is like a headline
it kind of shows how not represented the
average person is in media because like
what percentage of the planet are
christians muslim you know
that all of those people don't believe
in gay marriage
the majority anyways so like is it
should it be that surprising that a host
on a tv show
would have a disagreement on this issue
is that really worthy of a media matters
article or are you guys just admitting
that there is like no representation of
how many people on the planet tim 2.38
billion are christians are christians
wow yeah now do much less than muslims
well lauren i don't know if you know
this but the only reason that you could
ever oppose the left-wing orthodoxy on
uh matters of human sexuality is if you
actually just like specifically hate
people for being gay that's it two
billion yeah so like if you if so so if
you take
islam and christianity together we're
talking about four point three eight
billion people did you pull up
majority of the earth of the earth you
can't have them represented that is a
shocking opinion no no
look media matters i think i think
they're allowed to have their opinions
on whatever they want the problem is
that the headline of that article is
just
stupid
but it's just a panelist it says panel
lists and i think it was okay no so it
was alec brusowitz and sheamus
alex agreed with you if i'm not mistaken
he said that he believed in this this
fictional i'm okay with gay marriage
bruce said i'm okay with gay marriage
personally okay whatever but the stuff
that's come after it it's been messed up
so i was the person who said the true
things and you guys got attacked
the true thing is
is that the truth ian i'm not sure we
had jason whitlock on he said he
disagreed with gay marriage we talked
about it i said i i thought it was a
good thing there are many people that
were formerly democrats that when this
issue was settled they were like i can
vote republican now because that was a
big deal for me now i think if you want
to talk slippery slope the issue is if
it's bad it's bad and you you call it
bad i don't think this i don't think
it's a slippery slope to be like
consenting adults can do what they want
children can't consent they never will
be able to and you're not going to
change that no matter what yeah so i and
this is the thing i um would agree that
it's a bad art it's a bad argument to
say this thing which is like otherwise
good could lead to this bad thing so we
shouldn't do it i mean my argument is
that marriage is between a man and a
woman and because enshrining these
unions which are
not representative that in a road the
family incorporating those into our
definition of marriage legally is a bad
thing to do it will lead to other bad
things and i oh are we going to say oh i
can't believe how left wing your take is
marriage is obviously between a
christian man and a christian woman oh
yeah you're talking about christian
marriage so there's there's legal
marriage which is a just a legal union
you go to the courthouse you sign some
papers and then you have the joint bank
account you don't get taxed when you
give your wife six hundred grand but
then the marriage exists there's
christian religious christianity it's
like a spiritual blend yeah yeah well
there's sacramental marriages yeah yeah
yeah and you gotta define what you're
talking about when you when you're
comfortable with who can do it because
like
legally they everyone has the right to
get married i mean i think for the most
part every adult in this country right
at the moment has the there are there
are some states where so this is
actually funny i think my brother was
looking into this what states in the in
the country allow cousin marriage what
states allow gay marriage and what
states allow gay cousin marriage
and i think new york might be the only
one i don't know let me let me find it
wait
that allows all three is that what
you're saying
well it's just two have we really
reached equality if people can't marry
their dogs
um no no okay first yes maybe maybe
wait hold on in arizona first cousin
marriage only if both parties are 65 or
older wait one is interesting
because they're not going to have kids
they're afraid of inbreeding yeah yeah
yeah interesting arizona
eugenics that's super cool so i think
not eugenics but that yeah yeah yeah
look
new york
and california allow you to gay marry
your cousin
wicked why do they make fun of alabama
like your first cousin oh wait hold on
so uh so
what's
let me see if i can pull this up yeah
where's uh so in the s in the south you
can game area actually no no no hold on
hold on let me see
by state uh let's see well wait a minute
well i suppose because the the federal
government court has ruled so all that
you got to do is look you can see south
carolina georgia um
what do we have is that is that alabama
which state is that one that's
mississippi right yeah yeah
mississippi's on the left i don't know
these puzzle pieces puzzle pieces and
florida that's right
they do allow
oh yeah alaska hawaii
surprisingly you can gay mary your
cousin in a large portion of this
country wow but it's most blast
you know there's interesting questions
there about
the challenge of the libertarian
argument
so we were talking about the moral
foundations the other day and one of the
moral foundations is like
would you allow two consenting adults
in any circumstance their like their own
private you know life and the argument
for gay marriage was always like two
consenting adults in the privacy of
their own home whatever they want it's
like what if it's like a daughter and a
father yeah i no because inbreeding it's
dangerous at least from what we know
about scientifically
well i don't i i don't think that
liberty is even for the child the
dangerous for the uh
the kid that would be in the
relationship with their father
like forget the whole eugenics if she
was 18 i guess if she's a concepting
adult yeah
but i think there's like i'm not i don't
know the science on inbreeding but i
know that historically it can get pretty
bad i had a mouse that inbred with its
child and had another mouse that had a
breathing problem and i rest my case
[Laughter]
source i don't know
you had you had a mice that you had as
pets that were basically they just kept
breathing and breathing and they're
breeding with their kids my source the
british
although i think humans came from in
breeding in breeding each other eating a
bunch of mushrooms and then breeding so
maybe just the weak and breads die off
and then the healthy ones create a new
species
so why do you believe that oh it's just
a thought
iron you can marry your dad what and
what rhode island you can gay marry your
dad or your son
uh oh wait wait wait hold on
okay no i guess you can't get married
it's weird some states rhode island has
repealed its criminal incest statute
it seems kind of weird to me it's very
complex there but there are real
challenges to the libertarian argument
because
as ian was mentioning there's there's
there's risks like there's a reason why
you don't do it you have deformities and
and serious problems and so that's why
there's laws against it but i genuinely
think as we move towards this anyone can
be anything and do whatever they want
phase of reality or what like people are
trying to create you're going to see a
lot more of this i i'm willing to bet
that we're you know 10 or 20 years out
from
contending adults can do whatever they
want in any capacity that's where the
pendulum swings that's how that's like a
weird part of reality like the kings of
the old they would marry their daughter
to their cousin to keep the bloodline
what they would call i don't think they
would call it pure but it was to keep
like all the money in the family and all
the power in the family basically
i believe the ancient egyptians would do
that with their royalty as well i'm
curious how common that was among royal
families apparently was really sickly as
a result of oh yes siblings is also yeah
yeah uncle inis is is illegal they say
individual statutes very widely rhode
island has repealed its criminal incest
statute and only criminalizes incestuous
marriage
ohio targets only parental figures so
that means a brother and sister
i think would be allowed two brothers
could get married
that's okay that's really interesting so
you've got the laws around like okay you
don't want to have incest because
obviously that's going to cause problems
with the kids but then you look at
people who have like serious diseases
that genetic diseases that they can pass
down to their kids like do they outlaw
them breeding no that's what the nazis
did so they're not like if yeah that
there's the problem so if you're gonna
ban these people from it because of
birth defects and problems then why not
ban people with disease diseases that
they'll pass down and that's the
argument the left will come out when
they say you're a fascist for not
allowing brothers to love each other i
don't think more of wrong makes it the
other wrong better you just don't you
want less wrong stuff also i'm not this
is not um an argument from like moral
foundations or anything but one
objection that comes up
in my mind immediately is that you know
who is related to to whom you know who
the siblings are you you don't go around
doing genetic tests of everyone to know
if a person has a disease no in iceland
they do
interesting they have an app where they
have to you ever have you heard this in
iceland they have an app to check to
make sure you're not cousins hmm
because it's like an isolated population
yeah i saw a reddit post the other day
where someone was like very visually
disabled like you know arm issues face
issues like so you could see it like
right away and she
put a little tick tock up that was like
oh people told me i shouldn't have kids
but i did and she's holding her baby and
the baby is clearly very deformed too
and all of the people on reddit were
like you shouldn't have you shouldn't
have you shouldn't have which was very
interesting so like
yeah this conversation has been
happening since the beginning brings up
a really really great point but that
will bring us to
strange a strange position if
what is the argument
for for the laws banning
parental or lineal or direct family
relationships and it is typically
because of
the likelihood of the increase or the
creation of deformities but then you you
argue to people who already have those
deformities have a right to have kids
and they do
yeah so well i think i don't
there's but there's a good argument to
be made nature did not intend for people
to reproduce or procreate with their
siblings i don't think there's an
argument to be made that like nature
didn't intend people with disabilities
to procreate wait say that again i don't
i mean there's a good argument to be
made look nature did not intend people
who are directly related to procreate i
don't i don't think that there's an
argument to be made like nature does not
entice people with disabilities
because most people with disabilities
today wouldn't even survive in a natural
state without our extreme scientific
like inventions that keep them breathing
and going into hospitals every day so
like nature literally intended for them
to die so i would argue that a person
should not get married and start a
family unless they are in a position to
take care of that family for themselves
but if they are able to do that it
doesn't matter if they have a disability
or not it's their choice i think tribal
history was very incestuous when there
was only like 12 people they won they
would have to there's no other choice
and that's kind of where it all began
we've really gone down the rabbit hole
let's find back out
so speaking of look what disney's done
to us yes
guys guys okay all right can we just
talk about something serious for a
minute we have this story from live
science us government reported proposed
nuking the moon newly released documents
reveal james why is the moon flat tim
tim u.s government report
discuss his plan to nuke the moon
my name is brandon spector in our latest
report the us government has proposed
nuking the moon newly released documents
reveal
this just ends the moon
so this is a real story what are they
trying to find out if it's hollow or how
hollow is wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait hold on who wait u.s
government report proposed but they
proposed nuking the moon is this like
the big ask you know um
version
i actually think if i were to run for
office it would be in the position that
we should nuke the moon so tell me more
about this is this dude what why are
they doing this they say include nearly
600 pages reports proposals contracts
and meeting notes reveal some stranger
priorities a department department of
defense program that ran from 07 to 12
but only became known to the public in
2017 blah blah blah
they say new documents suggest they were
more than investigating the entire cache
of documents yadda yadda perhaps most
intriguing look how long oh okay yeah so
so the document here says let me read
this the various advanced technologies
the collections include transversable
wormholes stargates and negative energy
high frequency gravitational wave
communication warp drive dark energy and
the manipulation of extra dimensions and
many other topics that will sound
familiar to fans of science hold on i
actually i have this so so the proposal
says uh people are talking about cousin
marriages uh it's time to just end it
all let's nuke the moon honestly there
you go yeah that's it
the moon let's go deeper trans
dimensional waves is that what they said
so they're doing like i saw something
about pregnancy down there what is so is
that where the aliens made people
pregnant
yeah unaccounted for pregnancies did you
guys hear about this they say the latest
foia document dump arrived just three
weeks after british tabloid the sun
obtained more than 1500 pages related to
alleged ufo encounters
catalogued by the aatip
including among the documents was a
report on the alleged biological effects
of ufo encounters on humans the report
listed paralysis apparent abduction and
unaccounted for pregnancy the side
effect yeah right they just didn't want
to talk about it they're like oh by the
way i think i had sex it's like some
woman she did on her husband and then
she comes back and he's like how did you
get pregnant she goes aliens
that explains it i just pulled up that
they look like they were trying to nuke
the moon to tunnel through it why would
they want to tunnel through the moon i
don't build
why do you space
that you can just say anything no matter
how ridiculous and i'm just gonna have
your background do you not think aliens
are demons that's beside the point
oh yeah so like a lot a lot of people
are actually reporting on the the
release of these documents we have this
um from new york post as well
crowd control heat weapons
killer space lasers all right you know
i'm listening what is this it
mirrors an energy source to fire
lasers atmospheric absorption scattering
and it's blowing up a missile or
something
well maybe they're doing a bit oh so
they can spray a laser into the
atmosphere and then make it spread out
when it hits the atmosphere
it's all the lights are pointed together
so the single point
you know what happened someone got drunk
at nasa and forgot to write up their
proposal and they're just like i'll
write something so yeah i'd be wild that
no one will question it it's like the
craziest cultists are in the government
i mean they have all the power in the
world literally they're the most
powerful people in the world and like
who knows if they're dropping acid and
taking mushrooms and like what they'd
really probably believe it's real i mean
a lot of people do it micro dosed and uh
went a little over and then nobody's
planned you know you know what happens
we're victims of our own storytelling so
you know what what happens on youtube is
uh we'll use phrases as an example oh
yes is it my opinion on furries i think
the reason people identify as furry is
because they grew up watching looney
tunes and anthropomorphized animals so
they want to then when they're older
they dress like cartoon animals i
thought about this because i realized
like you see these memes about furries
and i'm like they're not dressing like
animals they're just singing like bugs
bunny and like the big white hands and
everything sometimes they're dressing to
hook up with lola bunny it's the amount
of rifle that so sola made into
depending on who you ask we've had
people super chat and say it's not about
just like sex it's about being it and
being that thing and i'm like yeah it's
because they watched anthropomorphized
animals as kids if that idea didn't
exist they wouldn't have it so what
happens is you'll get someone you know
1947 and the government's like if they
find out about our nuclear you know
programs it's going to be bad so just
lie and say it's aliens so turn them
into furry so they don't know anything
so then the media reports aliens some
little kid reads and goes whoa aliens
grows up believing that story and then
enlists to join the ufo program
genuinely believing it was aliens the
whole time and they're being lied to and
then they tell people i've seen some
weird stuff man i think it's aliens that
kid then grows up being like whoa aliens
are real the guy from nasa told me i i
better go work there and they just it
perpetuates them bob lazar is
notoriously made publicly humiliate
humiliated basically publicly by saying
zeta reticuli and the aliens he saw and
i think that was just red herrings that
they fed them because they're like this
guy they tell their scientists
so if they ever go rogue then they're
going to look like idiots if they
actually knew they were working on
drones he said he saw a little green man
yeah they probably had a stuffed
literally a stuffed animal sitting in it
they wanted at a carnival and they're
like they put it in the
the story later to book it was a puppet
yeah
translating them yeah exactly yeah no i
i'm tho i don't doubt the drone program
though tesla was working on some cool
technology in the i think there was an
api that went in there and took it nuke
the moon do we have to i think we want
to nuke the poles on mars mount rushmore
on the moon yes mount rushmore on the
moon
you know we're trying to put trump's
face on the moon quite frankly i think
it looks better
okay all right let's compromise we nuke
the moon
to make an engraving of trump's face
there we go oh i wonder what media
matters is going to say now they're
going to be like far right calls for
nuking the moon to create a portrait of
trump
yes and they're right they're absolutely
correct
yes and if you would like to help us on
our mission become members at
timcast.com it's the only way we'll do
it we should crowdfund
i mean
yeah can we can we crowdfund the moon
yeah there might be laws against that i
think that would probably not be legal i
don't know you can't nuke other
countries but the moon isn't a country
yeah should it be and and you know what
happened
all of the flat earther people who think
the moon is a space station is spying on
us would be like yes i'll give you money
please
yeah
do it did you guys ever hear about that
guy who built his own rocket ship and i
think he died
huh yes sounds about right i don't hear
about this
it was like he's like a flat earther or
something did he
yeah oh my gosh wait no i i think i
don't i don't know it's that guy in
homemade rocks
well there's a lot of guys who made
homemade rockets but there was oh i
think this might be it yeah
no no this was just a daredevil
disparage this guy uh he was just trying
to do it but i read a story about a guy
who like made his own rocket because he
wanted to prove the earth was flat or
something and then he like he died oh my
gosh
flat earthers are funny physics is
pretty cool
a guy made a rocket and died physics is
cool i mean
he thought the earth was flat i'd say go
with the physics on this one guys
it's round it looks very spherical from
space and and through measurements have
you ever been a space ian horizonal uh
longitude and latitude have you ever
been to space
uh not not not consciously
how do you know then uh i've seen
pictures pictures how do you know
they're not just fishing
i've seen streaming live from the iss
fisheye lens
you think that they're they're not
actually streaming live from the
audiences around a bro but this is the
point that they make
antarctica can you yeah have you ever
are you really sure you're you
how do you know what you are tim like
come on guys at some point physics is
real
right that's not my point my point is
when you talk to flat earthers no matter
what you say they have an answer
yeah you're like i don't talk to them
no i do you don't want to be debunked i
don't too scared you're right
like tens of thousands of years ago they
thought it was really flat they thought
it was on the back of a turtle or
something no different culture is about
different on the back of it and they
were like if you sail too far west
you're gonna fall off the earth so they
didn't and then the one no i don't think
that's true the the story is that uh
eratosthenes
accurately calculated the circumference
of the earth by measuring shadows at two
different points at the same time or
something yeah and it's funny because
the flat earthers are like how was he
able to coordinate that how did he do it
if if he didn't have a cell phone and
i'm like oh geez people couldn't
communicate over long distances back
then like fire didn't exist smoke didn't
exist and general timing didn't exist
it's just ridiculous yeah he he had two
towers he measured their shadows and
said how here's the here's how you know
how big the thing is on we're on and
then
apparently we never thought the earth
was flat because as soon as we
discovered seafaring you'd see things go
over the higher over the horizon boats
would appear to go down as they got to
the you know to the horizon too far away
and said they were like we're on a big
ball
yeah that must have been super ancient
before they even realize like the
horizon bends when you look out at the
ocean that's the turtle shell you guys
are gonna be so mad when you find out
we're on a turtle like can you imagine
like you died
don't say lsd
because it's obvious
yeah don't tell me this turtle's on dmt
what's sustaining this turtle
it's called
the world
where
[Laughter]
oh yeah it's hindu mythology and then we
enter the kali yuga and the world turtle
flips around or something is that what
happened i don't know dude
if i died and then like
could see the the world turtle i'd be
stoked i got a pleasure it was a turtle
if you guys could either watch the
formation of the of the solar system and
as fast as you wanted just to see it
happen or have a conversation with jesus
what would you pick jesus i talked to
jesus yeah he would tell me
yeah
jesus would tell you all about all of
that stuff
i would watch the universe personally
you what would you you said jesus yeah
but tell you what though exactly i don't
know i feel like he's just a guy that
got taken out of context well i guess it
depends on what context are you talking
to jesus like right now yeah if you
could just have a real conversation with
him while he just loses god right now so
basically what you're saying so
basically what you're saying is you're
not talking about conventional prayer
you're saying you ask god any question
he gives you the answer yeah he's not
going to go back to like three like you
don't like guaranteed it's gonna be
like it might make christians no longer
christian if they meet him they're like
whoa he actually is just a guy like if
you could go back to 3ad and sit down
with the dude and talk to him or
whatever when he was 24 or something
yeah i'm sure a bunch of uh saints got
persecuted boiled and hung for just a
guy i heard that there was a there's a
book about it actually that the roman
emperor at the time and a bunch of uh
roman oligarchs made christianity to
disempower the jews because they had too
much power
but i think that
to get to your actual question you have
to have
it's like
would you would you want to talk to a
guy people think is god or would would
you want to see the universe form those
are two very very distinct questions
well obviously i would like to have a
supernatural experience watching the
formation of the universe but if the
premise is that jesus is god i'd be like
i'd much rather talk to jesus well
there's no premise
that's why i just asked the question
blindly like that so you need to ask the
question so you have different belief
structures obviously
that's why i'm interested for people who
believe jesus is god they'd be like i
would like to talk to jesus yeah i would
think i would think for you and you're
like it was just a guy it's like well
that's a different question i don't know
if he's just a guy but i'd still rather
watch the universe get formed because i
don't know if there's a binary star
collision or not okay but okay so you
watch the universe get formed and you
don't really get too many answers okay
great it formed somehow science
whatever turtle giant turtle
but you get to talk to jesus and you get
to find out the fate of your soul in the
afterlife like why wouldn't you
well i want to find out no
a z pinch that caused the sun to like
overcharge itself and then spit out all
this matter or if it was a binary star
collision that caused it to argue that's
more important than your eternity yeah
but what's the guarantee that jesus
would tell you about your attorney i
actually think that's totally talking
like i don't know i think about the
universe forming too i wish i could go
with you i kind of think that
god or jesus would say you know you need
to live your experience and live your
life and and
well no that's my point is we can pray
now and ask god questions now yeah yeah
it's true but i think you get an answer
through your own human filter
i think sometimes i think people can
absolutely pray and and deceive
themselves and think they're hearing
from god
for themselves can i just choose to
believe we're on the back of a turtle
yeah i mean tim you look you guys that's
called psychosis this just in the
universe has been discovered to be on
the back of a turtle more at nine
o'clock i guess what is evidence really
you know just agreed upon
information
oh it's held up by elephants yes yeah
elephants on the turtles back that is
crazy like why
somebody was smoking when they thought
of that
they're like you know the earth it's
flat no like it is yeah held up by
elephants
where what are the elephants on here it
is the turtle this book that i mentioned
is called creating christ how roman
emperors invented christianity
uh
and when i heard that it was just like a
couple weeks ago someone mentioned it to
me i thought that is not far out of the
question can we it is very unfair
guys can we get a vote um all in favor
of giving ian title of blasphemer
well think think about it logically
everybody
the jews at the time had massive
political power and the romans were
really authoritarian so i could see they
would stop at nothing you could make
anything sanhedrin and you know the
roman government to destroy what they
had created for the purpose of getting
rid of the power of i don't know
anything about the same hedren when did
get created the powerful jews in rome
from my understanding i don't know just
using big words like bosh
tell me a black blaspheme for me mauryan
oh let me tell you about it
why would they destroy what they created
and allow the group they were trying to
destroy through it to do that as well um
i would imagine because there's
generations later and the people were
changed at that point maybe people were
like wow what have we done let's rectify
or stuff like that maybe i don't know
much about what you had mentioned what
year was you know what years it all
happened this is the reports that it was
like in 70 a.d or something that they
got that they did this i'm really i
think i think
we i don't know if we can really serve
these conversations
very well without
scholars
yeah but well that's also what i'm
saying is i'm not just talking about
catholic scholars the scholarly
consensus atheistic or otherwise is that
jesus christ
existed right i believe he exists but
there there are no scholars i mean
mythicism is a fringe position mythicism
is the belief that jesus didn't exist
he's completely fictional that is the
slim minority view yeah i don't think
that i think i would imagine he existed
but that could they call it the roman
they called the roman catholic church
roman dude
rome was the empire like
why does the empire have a religion
let's
let me pull up this story that is that
is directly related to what ian is
talking about timcast.com reports boston
police launch hate crime investigation
after teenagers attack white women with
braids the attacker is the latest in a
series of crimes committed by juveniles
in the city's district a1 and i was also
add this has nothing to do with what ian
was talking about yeah but you're right
segway
awesome
i was like can i do the worst possible
segway i loved it i thought the story
was interesting because we've been
seeing an increase in crime we've also
been seeing wokeness going crazy so when
there was a report that they're like
it's racially motivated because the
woman was white and she had braids these
guys basically attacked her because she
was culturally appropriating braids
and the city is saying it's a hate crime
is that what it's
can you read that bit
so they said uh the boston police are
investigating a possible racially
motivated crime after a group of
teenagers attacked a woman in the city's
downtown the headline is a white woman
with braids but was it because she had
braids that's so that's that's the
initial reporting i saw
is that police noted in the report the
woman was in distress and highly
animated oh here we go the girls
allegedly punched and kicked the woman
and pulled her by the hair because she
was uh here we go
one of the victims said a group of girls
called her a white expletive with braids
who should not wear her hair in that
style because she was not black before
assaulting her the girls allegedly
punched and kicked the woman and pulled
her by her hair
okay so if this never actually happened
and instead
uh uh a leftist invented a story of this
happening to a black person like
completely fabricated uh a hate crime
like this it would be in the national
news cycle for days and days
no they're not going to talk about this
i always like pointing out that bill
maher a week after covington was
debunked still maintained the lie
because the dude just like doesn't know
how to google stuff
i get nervous about the term hate crime
it seems like it's too subjective i i
like that it's finally being used both
ways though like there was just a
calgary police tweet where it was just
some graffiti that said like fy people
why people shouldn't exist anymore and
they're like investigating a hate crime
and people were seething molding into
comments and i was like well you know
what this is where we're at
and i it should be fair if they're going
to investigate it one way they have to
do it the other but that is giving in
to ridiculous laws
if they might like i i think we should
have equality if you attack someone you
attack them if it's just like well we
think you did it for a specific reason
related to like how they looked now you
get worse punishment i'm like no dude
assault assault batteries battery
motivations
it's it's a it's it's it's weird in my
opinion i don't like hate crimes i
remember that um new york subway attack
like a few weeks ago where the guy shot
like 26 people or something no one died
ten people like ten people okay
they were like we're investigating this
this is not but we believe it is not an
act of terrorism i'm like what the guy
terrorized everyone on the train that's
terror i don't care use the word or
don't but it's like that they're using
that word like hate crime terror attack
to make it more dangerous but it's like
how do you know it was crazy every
headline would be like oh if the if it
were the other way around like a white
guy who shot up the place they'd be like
if this were a brown man they'd call it
a terror attack like that's
yeah they're they're very reluctant to
apply that label to anyone who isn't
white basically
i don't like it the terror attack thing
is new 20 years new i don't like it well
i mean it's terrorism right if i
understand properly the actual technical
definition of terrorism is you're trying
to use fear to get people to comply with
your political motive
this guy had posted a bunch of black
nationalist stuff yeah like the joy that
when the auntie remember the antifa guy
who had the 9mm with the drum
and it was like in ohio or whatever do
you guys remember that
they said that it wasn't politically
motivated they said it wasn't leftist
violence and i'm like dude
i don't care what you think yeah if a
dude's posting crazy antifa stuff and
then goes and shoots people up my only
assumption is this is his driving
motivation yeah the world view he lives
in now was the reason he pulled the
trigger was to enact communism i don't
know he was a far-left extremist who
engaged in actually he definitely
intentionally set it up and did it well
okay sorry i was thinking about you can
literally be a terrorist as long as
you're on the left though and they just
won't mention it do you know dr tedros
the head of the world health
organization i just found out last week
he was literally a member of a banned
terror organization
yeah the tig gray people's liberation
army look it up right now uh dr tedros
he's the guy who we got all our updates
for from the world health organization
on covid uh
it's
people's liberation go to his wikipedia
and look at early life and it just says
that uh oh he was a part of this little
group uh the tigray rebels and then if
you click he denies his name
no he was literally a part of their
political party for years he was even
been accused of supplying arms they
killed a bunch of people they were a
banned party in ethiopia for terrorism
tedros was a member of the tigray
people's liberation front the leading
group in a coalition of movements known
as the ethiopian people's revolutionary
democratic front in a successful bid to
overthrow mengistu hail mariam now click
on tigre people's liberation front
notice how they don't mention in that
sentence at all that it's a terror
organization no no it's an ethnic
nationalist organization paramilitary
group and banned political party
can you imagine if any of us were a part
of that what our wikipedia page would
look like it sure as hell wouldn't be a
single sentence not mentioning ethnic
nationalist terrorists or band but they
just whoo
the head of the world health
organization
that's insane that is i think it's not
like unbelievable forgiveness and like
it's not unbelievable when someone's
radicalized who was we had on the show
when someone's radicalized when they're
young and they're in terror
organizations
was like for like 10 or 12 years he was
like a hardcore basically doing what
this guy was doing and then snapped out
of it and was like and basically now
he's talking about de-radicalization and
stuff he's big talks a lot about the
azov and ukraine and how we're if we're
funding that we're funding a radical
ethnic
you know cleansive group
um so maybe you know i don't want to
like this guy i'm not a big fan of the
world health organization but i'm not
just because he was in an organization
when he was younger doesn't mean that he
wasn't younger he was like a politician
a part of this group like an adult and
the it's the point isn't even like him
about him personally it's
the fact that this isn't mentioned
anywhere that he can become the head of
the world health organization with no
fuss about the fact that he was part of
a terrorist oh yeah imagine noise talks
openly about his experiences if he was
hiding it that would be a completely
different story yeah
yeah yep no it's insane put the camera
on me i mean i mean
sorry yeah i mean no i'm eating
maraschino cherries of course yeah
what were you going to say sheamus well
i was going to mention something earlier
but sheamus
exactly hold on
i knew i knew someone was going to go
there i don't know what i'm doing to
inviting this co invite this kind of
what's that what's that orange there's
nothing it's nothing yeah what is that i
only see so anyway
uh no i mean of course this guy's
facebook page as you mentioned her
social media accounts were filled with a
bunch of left-wing rhetoric and their
argument is uh i actually don't even
really make an argument about it they
just don't say anything but that's
ridiculous i mean if somebody committed
a massacre in their social media was
full of them posting things like the
goblins watch me and like the voices
tell me to shoot people we wouldn't
assume that that was unrelated to them
going out and hurting people and yet
when someone's posting like incendiary
insane left-wing
rhetoric that's just not even a
potential motivation for why they would
go out and kill people once they do you
know look i can't speak for right-wing
channels
i don't know
but um
when when
you have these prominent left-wing
podcasts just outright lie about all of
this stuff they'll be like you know
you'll mention this and like no he isn't
you'll be like he's a member of the
group no he's not and you're like i'm
reading about it right now no you're not
like the taylor lorenz thing is just
yeah hey you know they linked to her
private address no they didn't
yeah they did
it's not her home okay well it is but
it's also her i guess it's our work i
just said that's your argument no no
they didn't know that debunked him they
don't do that
it's just like what's the point of even
trying to talk to these people i'm gonna
say right now i've said it before i'll
say it again what's the point of
negotiating with someone who will look
at like they'll look at this bottle i'll
say i have a glass bottle and they'll go
no you don't
i'm literally holding a glass pop no
you're not
okay
well if we can't agree on something i'm
literally doing then i know what's the
point of talking only to like um measure
emotions to like tone them down or tone
down yourself only to listen to their
feelings it's most about feelings with
people like that now it says that tedros
was a member of this group but what does
it say about lauren southern oh
let's not read my we don't we don't read
my wikipedia page okay tim this is good
should i read it sure lauren southern is
26. oh wow wow ancient way too young the
90s uh a canadian alt-right youtuber
what does that even mean alt right i
mean
they took out white nationalists since
our last episode congratulations look
what happens you highlight alt-right
it doesn't matter
[Laughter]
how nice hello man
wikipedia is a joke yeah but uh what
does it say about south africa up there
something about this one
um
she has been described as an advocate of
white genocide conspiracy theory for her
documentary farmlands you know what the
conclusion of farmlands is that there
isn't a white genocide but that we're
approaching steps where we have rhetoric
in government saying we need to kill
white people which i think pretty fair
right if government elected officials
are saying we need to kill boar that
steps towards genocide yeah
so like they they say i promote the
conspiracy theory
which i don't but whatever you know
i've heard a lot about it this is the
farm attacks where
white farmers were getting attacked in
south africa because they thought you're
colonialists and we kind of thing yeah
there's like
massive uh groups uh at the eff
blackland first that literally just
advocate killing and taking the land
from the boar they have songs about it
that they've sung like full-on hate
speech farmers just getting murdered on
their property for the crime of being
white and owning land like it's
horrendous you know racism is a problem
all around in that country amongst all
groups like different
ethnic groups like within just the
african context tribal groups are super
racist against each other that's like
very much a norm there unfortunately but
like
to not acknowledge
that it's happening in a political
context
is wild to me especially in the west
it's so obvious and out there too one
second of google but i guess as you
mentioned tim these people don't
understand how google works i guess they
don't have access to their own computer
they just lie
i have a slightly off-topic statement
i'd like to make seamus you said earlier
that you're from ireland or you're no
i'm not i'm not this is the thing
why are you doing this like people are
gonna like start calling me a poser i
never claim this my question is i it
sounds like ireland is how you would say
the word island with an irish accent
ireland oh it's
ireland oh that's interesting is that
real i don't know oh that was my
question i don't i don't think i'm i
don't think people are from the object
let me look up the etymology i got a
test here come out g black and tans come
out and fight no you're gonna fight me
like a man yeah there we go he's a
chairman you're from chicago
what are you doing this is unbelievable
this is slander
i want to let everyone know that i was
just smeared by white nationalist lauren
southern for my ethnic identity
i watched it happen yeah exactly i was
like six feet away as a non-white man
definitely it's very effective
definitely the british were like those
are people on the island there was a
meme recently released uh they they can
track the data of um on google the most
searched countries within countries in
europe and it was showing like oh
ukraine is being the most searched
country outside of people's own country
in every country in europe except one
place
ireland and guess what their most
searched country was british
never
always watch your back it was they
they're most search countries they're
part of england british empire they're
like under the boot of the british
empire basically they don't want their
back from what i can tell a lot of
them the ira and the irish was it an
attempted revolution that they wanted
freedom from britain and like half the
country got it and the other half is
still british i don't know lauren's the
expert on this so the uh
i'm the i am by no means anyway an
expert no very little but uh you know
ireland was what uh enslaved by the
british for 800 years was it 800 yeah
yeah british colonists yeah and so they
were like not happy with it but uh lots
of catholics killed lots of but the
north was uh the orange is like the
orange order i think that that's
something to do with the dutch doesn't
it hmm that was protestant yeah that's
my understanding is that the orange
always represented the the protestants
the brits oh okay yeah yeah there you go
uh now you know uh i was there with you
wasn't i yeah when they were doing the
burnings yeah that was cool that was
really well the the peace wall makes no
sense but you guys were in ireland
together we were in ireland no one
invited me
on that day
we'll accuse him of being some kind of
irish terrorist on the podcast but to
actually go to ireland now he doesn't he
doesn't need to well they were burning
the irish flag on these like giant
pallets like built
insanely high um
it's like july the 7th or something i
can't remember but it was like a
northern irish holiday where they just
like burn effigies of british
politicians
the peace wall made no sense because
like one side was like pro-palestine and
one side was pro-israel and you're like
what does that have to do with what's
going on it's the foreign funding going
into each side no it's just tribalism
yeah it got to the point where this is
what that one was telling us he was like
if one side adopted a principle or idea
the other side would take the opposite
just for the sake of taking the opposite
well then yeah they had like obama and
nelson mandela on the irish side of the
wall and then they had yeah all this
like right-wing stuff on the northern
irish side it was really weird
come from like trying not to get to hear
people not to go to the other side
you're like no everything they're saying
is wrong don't even think about it it's
like right now yeah when a leftist will
say to me washington post didn't dox
anybody and i'll be like here's a link
to them no they didn't it's like they
just have to say that because they're in
a cult they go i know you are but what
am i right
and i'm like dude
i got no point talking to you all right
how about we do this i'll talk to you
we'll go to super chats if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends and let's read what y'all have
to say
after that particularly raucous
conversation
rylo says why is trump talking smack
about cnn plus when i can't even get
into truth social whatever man ubuntu
22.04 is out ian fedora or ubuntu
uh
i haven't used fedora i really have
liked ubuntu in the past so ubuntu what
it's a operating system yeah only the
cool kids don't know linux
it's for cool only cool guys
it means something like love of the
community or something yes like an
african something like we are one right
yeah steven valdez says are we seeing
the beginning of the end of woke i
wouldn't count on it humanity to others
just googled it
nobody nobody no wait can you repeat
that sorry
it is both the end and the beginning my
friends
and forever it will be uh leftism never
goes away because it just means social
decay and everything humans make breaks
down eventually what we can do is try to
be productive people and stave it off
but it's never gone forever
lua coder says don't forget that trump's
truth social has already flopped before
it started they violated the code
license of mastodon when they claimed it
was their own proprietary code yep well
that is true
i will say ian
called them out early for it before they
launched but was correct when they
launched they did not admit to it that's
my understanding
and
the platform's just been
yeah people have had a hard time getting
in they're all waiting they're like for
months or something you want to follow
the president i do he ain't here
like okay what am i doing not a lot on
twitter he's not even allowed on his own
website it's hysterical
yeah
mike sullivan says rather feed the
chickens well it is true uh we made i
think we made i'm pretty sure over two
thousand dollars today on chicken city
it is the number 31 most super chatted
show in the world in one month we had a
great chicken party before we went live
the babies baby's first chicken breast
babies got released for the first time
finally out of the brooders and they're
running around and they're all flapping
their wings for the first time because
they were really cramped in there and
then they had two two chicken parties oh
yeah two two whole parties it was uh it
was good fun this house is actually run
by the chickens it's true i went
downstairs and it was just chickens
everywhere
we are we are averaging at this point
probably like 1300 bucks per day
like tax day was really low nobody was
super chatting because everyone's like
groaning but today with the amount of
money that came in it makes up and
bounced out so it's probably like 1500
yo chicken city is going to fund so much
i was going to say you're going to get
to a point where chicken city is making
more than tim cast irl and you guys are
going to start getting like wolf of wall
street psychotic about it you're going
to be like dance chickens dance it's
going to be the opposite the chickens
are going to be running the roost you're
like can we please can we please be on
your show are you begging to be on
chicken city
i'm i'm actually willing to bet but
listen you got to understand
chicken city is
like it's almost like asmr with the
nature sounds good dogs and cats love it
so people put turn on on their tvs and
leave and the dogs just watch the
chickens
kids like it
we're launching we just put up a first
cartoon short gag which is a
family-friendly humor it's called
everyday life living with a rooster and
it starts with chickens is this the one
that we improv with the eggs and then
when the chicken tries talking to the
rooster he just screams no don't give
away the punchline that's that's that's
my that's our brilliant writing it's my
brilliant writing well it's funny but
the the gag is that rooster is just
always screaming non-stop yeah it's
actually not a game so you joke you joke
yeah it's not it's like it's true you
joke that we're gonna make more money on
that uh i gotta be honest i think the
market cap for family-friendly content
is much bigger than politics so get the
chickens doing toy reviews
oh my gosh
what if we do unboxing videos of
chickens we take the new chicken
egging
we are we are launching merchandise for
them and each of the main chicken cast
will have their own shirt
so there will be like a margaret shirt a
vanessa shirt a katarina shirt a carol
shirt a
and a roberto jr this is just like a
spin on women who make cats they're
children well we're just making funny
stuff and then there's there's margaret
has two babies and they're called the
twins maggie and bernie but because they
are identical which calm the twins but
then there's two black star girls which
are also the twins but they're black so
i was like we can call them the black
chicks or we can call them by their
names crow and raven but we can't call
them the twins because the twins are the
other ones who are a little older i i
would veer away from calling them the
black chicks oh no i meant that
literally i can tell
like they're they're they were like
they're they were young chickens and
they were black i call them the white
people right the whole time hey by the
way the chickens are grooming themselves
hard right now in chicken city
all right let's read more to anyway by
the way uh lauren i don't like the
comparison between cats and chickens on
any level someone who owns chickens is
not the same as someone who owns cats
it's not even it's not even
i suppose chickens are productive
they're productive and cool so this is
just slavery
well the more chickens you own the more
likely it is you have a family lauren as
opposed to cats right now the chickens
are in a protective pen
there is currently a pandemic right now
among chickens a pandemic and in
exchange for safety we've locked them in
a box they're not allowed to leave
so true gotta put some massive
benevolent
slavery
and we get their eggs
lord carbonite says hey y'all quick
question about taxing people less for
having more kids my uncle can't have any
kids because he's diabetic how would he
be affected by this tax love what y'all
are doing keep it up and smash that like
button smash that like button i don't i
don't think we should tax people who
don't have kids i think we should give
tax cuts to people who do have kids yeah
this is how would affect him he wouldn't
be touched aren't they doing that though
also if he got i mean if he
it was married and wanted to adopt
then i suppose it would affect him
yeah i'm nervous about people having
kids just to get the paycheck though
i've seen i've heard stories about
people that do that just to collect like
you know what do you call it but i think
there's security or well i think there's
a and i i sort of hear you but i think
there's a difference between
directly giving somebody income for
having kids and allowing them to keep
the money that they already earned
that's a good point because then it
still incentivizes them to work and it's
also like who who has a higher claim to
your money the children you need to
provide for or the government let's read
some more we got um
miss meltyface says lauren is awesome
three drink lauren is way more awesome
so before we record the members only
i'll just make sure lauren pours more
pappy it's propaganda also you know what
that is right no it's kind of gross to
be honest are you serious oh wow that's
a thirteen hundred dollar bottle yeah
oh my goodness i got out of the sauna
one night and i felt clean you know and
i sipped a beer and all it tasted like
was rotten food i was like what is this
and then a second later i took a second
sip and it tasted like that
that's actually i think that's 17. uh i
don't i don't know maybe it's 13. it's
the papi 12
i am someone who can drink like a nine
dollar five dollar bottle of
wine like
no more importantly you're this you're
someone who could drink a 1700 bottle of
whiskey and not know it lauren there is
a bottle of corn whiskey up there that
was 10 bucks try that one it's all yours
it's really good we should get that
sulfate free i love it i'm sure
corn whiskey i got the corn whiskey
because i was like sooner or later
someone's going to come here has no idea
what any of this is and they're going to
drink the 10 whiskey there's also
colloidal gold over there i got a little
bit of you can drink that's what ian
brought to the to the totally into it i
think it helps your neurons become super
conductors ardwick says on average ian
is a solid 10.5 that's a little bit
better than yeah that's all i need
all right for shameless the irish hobo
so shameless rdc says to everyone how
much you want to bet that fox will take
back wallace
are you are you chris that like very
expensive so she here's the thing she
said she was going to grab a drink i
said grab me a cup i didn't think she
was going to get the most expensive
thing off the shelf as it happens she
did and i'll be honest it's been
enjoyable it's it's nice to sip on i'm
not trying to take more i think that
thank you lauren went and grabbed the
most expensive whiskey off the shelf
more on the news at night i wonder
how many like whiskey aficionados are
you know face palming i know the plastic
it's just a woman moment i naturally
just
gravitate towards the most expensive
item in a man's house and take it
it's very pure looking look at that it
looks really cool
wow that's strong john
all right here's a good one john
morganaier says tim please stop saying
john you are 33 years old one it's
creepy two i'm turning 30 32 this year
get it right so i made i make the joke
where it's like i know the demographic
so i can i can look in the camera and
say john you're a 33 year old white man
oh my gosh and someone's going to go huh
that was me
but i was like no i could also say
javier you're a 27 year old mexican guy
john's creeped out okay you could say
sheamus you're a 27 year old sheamus
sheamus
you are a 27 year old white male and you
are watching this show right now i'm
actually irish
you know there's going to be someone
named sheamus who sees that who's 27 i
don't know i don't think there aren't
that many of us yeah but in five years
it's actually not weird it's excellent
they just can't go giving it out to
everyone willy nilly
sheamus you're listening to this video
again when you're 40 years old
oh my gosh
when you're 80.
sheamus gonna be back i remember the
good old days
after i finally left tim cash that was
the best time of my life sheamus you
need to go back
don't listen to them don't listen to
them you guys ready for a bad joke
it's f i think it's funny but i mean
like dark razgriz says cnn plus being
canceled after three weeks is fine
because abortions are allowed up to 22
weeks in georgia oh my gosh i like a
crazy that's my seal of approval as a
joke well done
very dark
dark who yikes
all right all right
three why would it say ilit says you
guys need to watch network the 1976
movie this is cnn's prequel lol they
used to tell me i was that guy in that
when i was making videos in the early
days those 607 go to the crossmak
channel on youtube if you want to see it
man i was like that guy from network
there it's all i was like so red
red-pilled you know i was out of my mind
and i just didn't know how to express it
rob matt says please get elon musk on
the show um oh let me call up
yeah i will tweet i'm going to tweet at
elon right now i'm going to tweet
i'm doing it yeah here we go tim that's
the thing i have one million followers i
have one point one though you know what
to be fair he's been responding to like
random accounts
yeah he's watching him that's never
gonna work tim i'll hit him up oh my god
they're distant
yeah this is good because we can talk
about freeing twitter's code there we go
i have officially tweeted that out i
want to ask him about the birth rates
let's go let's see
there we go now pete there's there's a
ton of like weird lefties on twitter who
are going to see that and have no idea
what the context is
so um
hapitarian on twitter has tweeted at me
to like tweet random nonsense to see
what happens he's like tim should tweet
the and see what happens and i do and
like people are like i hate you
and then he was like tim should tweet
cake and see what happens and then
people are like pie no
pie is not no cake
twitter
where you go to get emotionally
destroyed that's right it's just a hell
loop peterson stays on that site yeah
you can hear something says my kids
thought the chicken city cartoon was
hilarious however my three-year-old did
run around pretending to be the rooster
all evening after watching it all right
i'm sorry i i i take that as a a a
compliment that's great
all right
let's grab some more super chats
get rich says hey tim love what you were
doing with tim cast very inspirational
lauren did you and luke have a thing
back in the day or mandela effect thanks
i i didn't screen that i just grabbed
one that said we're doing good with tim
cass so the rest of it i didn't actually
read yeah we dated briefly
both awesome people
mayor it's like it just goes quiet
well hey
do you want to talk about your personal
life
i was actually going to take the
opportunity to make fun of lou because i
like making fun of luke but i was like
wait no this might be yeah there's a
thing evidence that we don't screen
supercharged jean wilder made a pretty
good point about being talking about
your personal life and your private life
and they're different and i like that uh
private is like names and
dates and you know addresses and stuff
whereas personals like how you feel
about what happened to you in your past
and things like that roberto lara says
stelter was born in 1985. ian that was
an awesome interview with michael malus
drugs and god i think ian needs a show
called in ian's mind or calls work
called words with ian
thank you
just exploded people are like
it's uh it's michael malus episode 203
you're welcome
all right
patriot american says hey tim you
planning on working with the daily wire
on some of their shows would it be
possible to invest in some kind of video
game division i'd call it tim cast games
there have been
a variety of discussions the daily wire
on a lot of the things they're working
on it's all i can really say uh
obviously if we're over there where what
we do at the daily wire is very much
aligned in terms of like you know we
want to change culture they're different
from us in a lot of ways but we we like
them they're fun people and we've talked
about shows movies books
and you know
we'll see we're crazy over here i don't
think the daily wire would ever do
something like chicken city
and and and that's why we're different i
think we're much more
i don't know is it younger i don't know
if younger is the right word and i'm
probably older than all of them except
for a lot of them yeah yeah yeah but i
suppose if you look at the way we
approach things it's from a very
different perspective or or operation
but we agree on so much about culture
the daily wire is never going to set up
a chicken coop and have chicken parties
right
you know but they're making movies so
they're they're taking the institutional
hill and i'm glad they are i mean jeremy
about the same age cool he's a month
couple months older than me oh there you
go i love that guy so i i certainly
think cj you know we'll see how things
play out we will
but uh big fan of daily wire guys
insane says fan of the show
i have a suggestion for a guest david
wood from act seven apologetics he get
he got an incredible testimony and i'd
like for y'all to talk about philosophy
and religion with david love you ian
love you too dog
yeah so you know one of the things i
thought about was like
do should we have someone actually just
pull like some of the best super chats
that we talked about a while ago i was
like while we're doing the show we
should have someone actually
take
good super chats and get us ready for
the best ones and then i was worried
that whoever did that would avoid
spicier ones because obviously
i'll be reading one i'll get halfway
through i'm not reading the rest of that
and sometimes i'll walk into traps like
speechless by michael knowles and things
like that and that's funny so i don't
want to get rid of that i wanted you
know just to
all right let's grab some more
we got too many super chats today by the
way i'm familiar with acts 17
apologetics i haven't seen too much of
their stuff so i want to refresh myself
so i went to their youtube channel and
they currently have 666
000 subscribers so so you all got to
subscribe you all gotta you'll gotta
change that ratio what's the history of
that actually
is it irresponsible for me to tell
people to restructure a channel i
haven't seen in a while all right i
think it's the wrong number stephen
bortlemay says marriage is a religious
custom that only became
i don't know what the word he was
bastardized when the state adopted it
for the purpose of stealing more money
from its civilians
i think the issue is that in this
country marriage is quite literally an
abrahamic institution rooted in the fact
that this country was founded by a bunch
of christians and it morphed into a
state institution but is still attached
to the church and that creates a very
serious problem in this country if
you're going to argue the separation of
church and state well then
yeah i don't know what you're doing that
was always my question when when uh the
property thing was happening
because they had that that musical where
jack black is like your nation is built
on separation of church and state and i
was like
i mean if that's true what is this what
power does a state have to regulate an
abrahamic institution but is it though
is it
is it what is it really separated yeah
no it's not completely right yeah and so
there there lies the big issue where i
was like
how is the state going to mandate
churches do a thing yeah you know i
don't know
i think i think the problem was the uh
the civil unions that they were talking
about back with the obama days in 08
didn't offer identical rights between
gay marriage gay couples and
traditionally married couples and then i
was like you can't do that and that was
i think that was the argument they used
to actually get gay marriage because it
was equal rights but i was like
i don't know how you you have a uh like
we have an institutionalized religious
component with marriage well well there
are a union
have the same rights as a traditional
marriage at the time the argument
because obama was like obama said he was
opposed to gay marriage and he said he
was in favor of civil unions but the
activist hillary right the activist
group said that there was there were
certain rights that were not afforded
civil unions as opposed to marriage and
that's why they wanted marriage and i
just said well then get those rights to
civil unions and are we happy and
they're like no we want the institution
and i was like
yeah well they want the word and this is
the thing i mean marriage is so there
are there are sacramental marriages uh
but also people who
marriage predates
the um
marriage i mean it goes all the way back
to adam and eve and so i believe it was
christians believe it was created by god
but we believe in a concept of natural
marriage it's not that it's specifically
in all instances something people do as
a matter of their religious faith it's
just that it has a definition and that
definition is that it's a union between
man and woman that's what's one of the
instrumental parts of what it means
carame says quote of the night by yours
truly lauren quote have we really
reached equality if people can't marry
their dogs effing gold did you say that
i think i did
the pappy's is hidden
i've said some wild things tonight we
have fireball downstairs you know you
don't gotta oh how about you know no
one's cracked open that corn whiskey i
just found out the waffle house is open
24 7 here so i'm going there after this
there is a waffle i was very close by
sheamus didn't crack the corn whiskey
sheamus you want to drink the corn
whiskey at waffle house with me after
are you on your
wasn't there incest in the adam and eve
story
so much
i don't think so no so well so the
argument is that they had what two kids
cain and abel kane abel and i think seth
is also mentioned i don't know if that's
an exhaustive list but yeah daughters um
that's not a question i could answer i'm
not sure i need to double check it's
been a while since i've looked at
genesis i believe kane abel and seth are
the ones that are mentioned those are
dudes though right um yes i believe so
so like did they no i don't know the
answer to that question i don't know
i don't have an answer there's no
mention of any other women though no
that's what i'm saying i don't have an
answer i don't know what the
significance of that is i don't it's not
necessarily an exhaustive list as far as
i understand of every of all
that they have yeah but with that well
no so we believe that adam and eve are
the priority like they're the first
human ancestors that all human life goes
back to uh the first two people i'm not
sure
two people isn't enough to create a
population that's the issue no i hear
what you're saying i don't have an
answer i don't know it says that
interesting question the sons and
daughters of adam and eve uh abraham
marrying his half-sister sarah lot and
his daughters
moses's father amram who married his
aunt joshuabed well sure and also be
careful too because i'm sure that's
there's a list of a number of instances
here but just because the bible is
describing something doesn't necessarily
mean it's condoning it so you got to be
careful oh yeah it's just explaining
that it happened i mean that was out of
necessity there were like 60 of them
what are they going to do you know you
got to propagate the species
all right
what is this
democratic detox says elon spacex will
help you far-right news people make
trump's face in the moon oh well thank
you
we'll consider it murf try says tim
nuking the moon would lead to a supreme
court case on citizens rights to nuke to
nukes under 2a let's see if they agree
with you
uh are you familiar with the second
amendment lauren am i familiar with the
second amendment are you have you ever
heard of it
no you know that's i say
right to own nuclear weapons
is that the second amendment yeah the
right to keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed does it say accept nuclear
arms the right to bear arms so true
bear arms
i already have bare arms see i roll my
sleeves up and that is my right
uh tim likes to bring people into this
it's because
from what i can gather is that his
belief is that technically legally we do
still have the right and if they want to
take that away or change that they need
to amend the constitution so
what would happen if tim cast tried to
buy a nuke
i don't know but i wonder if we got like
the highest degree of um licensing for
an ffl you know what's the limit
cultural enforcement that's when
cultural enforcement takes hold if you
start doing stuff like that like well
halliburton's got permits what grants
them the right to have these crazy
weapons someone was selling a missile
silo in like kansas for 300k
yeah people live in those yeah it's like
amazing you should buy one and have a
tim cast missile what if i want whenever
someone doesn't agree to go on the show
you can be like hey
where in the country am i allowed to fly
service to air missiles where
i don't know so the issue is at some
point we culturally decided that people
had no right to bear arms and i mean
that literally we used to have
privateers with cannons and all of a
sudden now you can't own a destroyer
disgusting yeah i saw someone drifting a
tank on twitter yesterday and it made me
very sad to think i will never drift a
tank unless no there's a connective war
zone there's a guy over here who like
not that far away owns a tank and he
invited us out is it like a working
original tank yeah it is so i could
drift a tank that's what you're telling
me you can buy a tank if you want
most women uh girls i'm told like ponies
and and hey babe are you watching this i
want a tank for your birthday
i would like a tank
jay stewart says disc world definitely a
cultural cornerstone also death has bony
knees i didn't realize that but take
your word for it
all right
uh
i don't know if i should read that one
let's see
nona says can you get can you try to get
tim keller on before he dies to
counterbalance your resident pep papist
is that you say papist pathos there
who's tim keller that's i don't know i'm
not sure
all right there was there was there was
something about a turtle that was really
funny but i think i lost that one
j doc says 11 of 12 apostles were
tortured burned crucified beheaded
stoned drawed and quartered quarters all
died for what they knew was true and not
before not for what they believed
interesting yeah if you think i think
governments are are totally fine killing
their own citizens to get their way
sometimes yeah but the point is why
would someone voluntarily die for a
story that they knew not to be true well
i don't know if they voluntarily died
well no but
it's it's it's a question of recanting
so if you're you're martyred it's
because you refuse to the problem of
your faith the person that told me that
they didn't recant is the government
elwood blues quote i want to ask him
about the birth rates lauren i have
never laughed so hard
when did i say that were you talking
about jesus
did i say that about jesus what was the
quote i don't even remember what i just
said
about the birth someone mentioned i
should get a sword i do think i need a
sword yeah uh is there like a brethren
i don't actually need a sword right now
the zelda the master sword oh yeah i
like the really sharp one no i don't
think you can no i i literally don't
think you can oh yeah rules rules and
regulations for uh streaming live but
the uh the zelda one is a toy a nice
blunt from the legendary it's
i have meteorite swords behind me
they're forged from meteorite they're
very expensive
literal serious question though link or
zelda
what do you mean if you had to pick one
what do you mean like one for what yeah
to play
then you
zelda if we're talking about melee where
she can transform to sheik because sheik
is good absolutely noah meta knight is
absolutely the most opp sure sure that's
that's meta knight's not in melee so
i gotta go with link on this one just in
general that that is
a mall sword from the legend of zelda
no i don't know what the sword rules are
but like the only stuff we display are
prop stuff like the i actually have so
you can't display a real gun behind you
yeah you can't really well i think you
might be able to but you you uh the
rules are that display of firearms has
to be in an approved setting and you
can't be manipulating or something but
i'm not entirely sure so why do i have a
toy sword when sheamus gets two steak
knives
because i'm a trustworthy individual who
has proven himself to expertly handle
those things those steak knives were for
peeling blood oranges who do you think
would win sheamus with two steak knives
or me with it's not even a question i
would win it's not even how much gravity
it's not even close to being around all
that kind of stuff all right let's read
some more super chats while we still can
huh
i only needed one i wanted i wanted to
see people talking about lauren being
drunk
i'm not i've had one glass cup she's
trying how was it by the way
it says for my girl lauren and jim cass
liquor bill drink that stuff yo
oh man yeah see you see you see how
expensive it is hosting lauren southern
absolutely she she called before and
she's like i only drink pappy it's an
investment
kevin nelson says twitter comments to
politifact denying biden shaking hands
with no one is the funniest thing i've
read in a minute it was amazing
politifact has a tweet that says you may
have seen joe biden shake hands with
thin air
period it never happened period and then
i'm just like
it is bold of them to say that you saw
something but it never
i am not holding up a pen
you may have seen me hold up a pen it
never happened or hey i've got a good
one i am not linking to her address
right right that's very good too same
idea
all right all right let's see if we can
um
wait actually i want to quickly correct
something you said it was expensive to
get me on this show do you know how much
my flight cost here how much was it
thirty four dollars
it was still too much all right and not
a single person no there was one person
on my flight wearing a mask
oh yeah that's awesome speaking of masks
my new cartoon watch it my friends
if you haven't already smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends
and if you want to see lauren southern
wielding
a fifteen thousand dollar sword forged
from meteorite go to timcast.com and
become a member i think you wielded the
sword last time too yeah i did uh
actually it's gonna be a video of seamus
and i fighting to the death with the
steak knives and the sword no i was
never voluntarily partaking in something
like that lauren will be allowed to
wield the 15 000 meteorite sword at
timcast.com for the members segment so
sign up if you want to check out that
segment you can follow the show at tim
cast irl you can follow me at tim kest
lauren what do you want to shout out oh
yeah go follow me at uh lauren
underscore southern on twitter uh lauren
southern on the youtubes
yeah
that one
my name is sheamus coughlin which is
super easy to spell
i have a youtube channel called freedom
tunes go check that out we just released
a cartoon today about the mask mandates
being repealed for airlines i think you
guys are really gonna like it it's
something like uh 20 000 views ahead of
our most viewed video of the last 10
uploads so the audience is really loving
it i think you guys are going to like it
as well one of these days i'm going to
hold a crystal ball up to the sky and
light a fire from a distance with it
with the sunlight and to prove to you
that throwing fireballs is real
so we can reinterpret what like magic
really is and stuff like that see you
later
oh like a wizard staff yeah i wonder if
back in the day was like had a staff
with a crystal and you held it up and
started a fire and they're like whoa
probably took a really long he'd be like
i will attack you with my fire spell
five minutes
later hold still for 20 more minutes
they always have their groups on them
they're like 15 guys all like aiming it
at the same spot or something the
wizards anyway what ian said was way
more okay lauren has her sword all up in
my shot i appreciate it oh is it over
your skin yeah you can see later on
which is hilarious it's gonna be a great
after show thank you ian for completely
throwing me off i would now like to hold
up a crystal and set something on fire
you guys can follow me on twitter
mines.com at patchlets instagram real
sourpatchlets and sourpatchlids.me
all right everybody the the tweet i sent
to elon has already 607 retweets
so uh elon man i'm a huge fan would love
to have him on the show so everybody we
will see you all over at timcast.com and
you will see lauren southern wielding an
expensive sword made from meteorites
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all there
you